Herzlich willkommen zur Folge Nr. 39 von Alternativlos.
Heute über Trojaner und Ransomware und insbesondere Wannacry.
Genau. Wir dachten uns, da ist so viel interessanter Stoff für eine kleine kurze Stammtischfolge, dass wir...
Wir hatten eigentlich was anderes vor.
Wir hatten eigentlich was anderes vor, aber dann dachten wir...
Summer non the Internet is wrong.
Genau. Das können wir natürlich nicht dulden. Ja, ihr wisst ja die üblichen entschuldigen, wieso wir letztes Mal wieder ein bisschen länger gebraucht haben seit der letzten Folge. Ihr kennt das ja schon. Deswegen wiederholen wir die jetzt nicht nochmal, um nicht noch weitere Zeit zu haben.
Das ist eigentlich ein Qualitätsmerkmal bei uns. Es braucht halt ein bisschen länger. Das ist missverstanden.
Das ist missverstanden. Weil es muss ein bisschen reifen und...
Ja, es braucht ein bisschen länger. Dafür ist es dann...
Ist sowieso ein gutes Steak.
Gut, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dafür ist es dann gut, weil vielleicht verkacken wir die Sendung ja auch.
Aber zumindest irgendwie haben wir eine Ausrede. Gut, Wannacry. Die News können wir vielleicht gerade kurz nochmal wiederholen für Leute, die es in 20 Jahren hören. Wir haben gerade einen Mailware-Befall rings um die Welt, der eine Ransomware auf Computer installiert. Das heißt also, der dafür sorgt, dass wenn die infektion erfolgreich ausgeführt wird, der Computer nicht mehr benutzbar ist, weil Files verschlüsselt werden. Und zwar mit einem Schlüssel, den der Angreifer dem Nutzer des Computers vorenthält und erst wieder zur Verfügung stellen möchte, wenn er da so irgendwie ein paar Hundert Dollar in Bitcoins hinüberwiesen hat. Soweit erstmal nicht so besonders neu, also diese Ransomware-Attacken gibt es jetzt schon seit einer Weile.
Da gehen wir erstmal die Timeline. Was ist passiert? Es ging los am Freitag. Ich hatte mich noch, weil ich in der Bahn saß. Und in der Bahn ist immer so eine Gelegenheit für mich, mal in Ruhe die Zeitung zu blättern und Newsseiten zu klicken. Und ansonsten bin ich häufiger angewiesen darauf, dass Leute mir Sachen zuschicken, die interessant sind. Aber in der Bahn hab ich Zeit mal selber. So, wenn nicht gerade Internet kaputt ist. So, und am dem Tag ging Internet in dem ersten Zug nicht. Aber ich hatte mir schon vorgenommen, ein bisschen News zu klicken. Nee, in den Zeitungen stand es noch nicht drin.
Ach so, war noch frisch.
Und dann hab ich halt über mein Mobiltelefon da getethert. Und dann gab's Meldungen von wegen, im britischen Gesundheitssystem seien ein paar Krankenhäuser betroffen von einer Ransomware. Und bis dahin klang das alles noch, naja, gut passiert.
Ransomware gibt's immer wieder.
So gern. War noch nicht wirklich abzusehen, wie schlimm es werden würde. Aber dann gab's die ersten Gerüchte, die hießen, dass NSA-Komponenten verbaut seien in dieser Ransomware. Und zwar gab's jetzt mehrere Leaks von Geheimdienst-Mailware-Komponenten. Erst die NSA und dann CIA. Beides ist am Ende auf Wikileaks gelandet, aber beides kam nicht von Wikileaks, soweit wir das wissen. Der NSA-Leak kam von einer Gruppe namens Shadow Broker.
Du hast doch gar nicht auf Wikileaks gelandet.
Ich bilde mir ein, dass sie das am Ende nicht. Okay, dann ziehe ich das zurück. Aber ist egal.
Die haben nur viel darüber getweetet.
Eine externe Gruppe namens Shadow Brokers, die so mit einem fake russischen Akzent gepostet haben. Man weiß irgendwie nicht, wer das ist.
Diese Shadow Brokers sind halt schon durchaus interessant.
Das war so ganz witzig gemacht.
Die haben ja von einer relativ langen Zeit gesagt, ihnen werden da halt Dinge in die Hand gefallen.
Vor einem Jahr ungefähr, das ist schon eine Weile her.
Von einer Gruppe namens equation Group, das war im August 2016. Das heißt also schon eine Weile her. Die haben gesagt, hier, wir haben die equation Group Cyberweapons und wir machen eine auction. Dazu muss man wissen, equation Group war in der Security-Branche schon länger dann das Codewort für Sachen, wenn sich halt Sachen gefunden haben, die der NSA zuzuordnen waren. Also man dachte, war es entweder der NSA oder die Briten, GSHQ oder vielleicht beide, auf jeden Fall eher NSA und die waren vielen dadurch auf, dass da halt eine signifikante Überschneidung zu den Snowden-Dokumenten gab und dass es halt um relativ fortgeschrittene Mailware-Kampagnen ging, die also auch ziemlich umfänglich Sachen aller Welt infiziert hatten.
Und angeblich gab es Code-Überlappungen mit Stuxnet.
Genau.
Das war so der erste Punkt, wo die Leute gesagt haben, okay, ist die NSA.
Und jedenfalls, diese Shadowbrokers haben damals gesagt, so hey, wir haben diesen Kram gefunden und die haben eine File-Liste veröffentlicht. Und haben gesagt...
Und ein kleines Sample.
Und ein kleines Sample. Und haben gesagt, so hier, wir haben den ganzen Kram und wir hätten gern 1000 Bitcoin dafür.
1000 Bitcoin ist eine ganze Menge Holz?
Genau. Also nach aktuellem Cross-Inky sowas wie 1,75 millionen Dollar.
Gut, aber nicht so viel Holz für Geheimdienste. War eh geil. Jedenfalls.
Damals war es ungefähr eine million Dollar. Und wir haben gesagt, hier könnt ihr alles haben. Aber wir machen eine sehr merkwürdige auktion, nämlich eine solch anamerikanische auktion, bei der du Geld überweist. Und derjenige, der am Schluss insgesamt am meisten Geld überwiesen hat, ist der Gewinner der auktion. Was halt eine sehr bizarre Form von auktion.
Die anderen kriegen die Kohle nicht zurück?
Genau, die anderen kriegen die Kohle nicht zurück. So ist es also mehr so eine Art Poker. Also wie tief sind denn deine Taschen? Wie viel magst du auf den Tisch legen insgesamt?
Jetzt muss man aber noch dazu sagen, dass bei Bitcoin von außen beobachtbar ist, wie viel Kohle fließt. Das heißt, es hätte einen sehr hohen Popcornfaktor gehabt, wenn die Leute da irgendwie die millionen in Bitcoin überweisen.
Genau.
Dann hätte man zwar nicht gewusst, wer, oder vielleicht hätte man es irgendwie raten können oder so, aber man hätte jedenfalls gesehen, wie die Geheimdienste sich im Kopf von Kragen wetteten. Und das war so ein bisschen das im Raum stehende szenario. Und die Leute haben sich also diesen Sample Code angesehen. Und nicht nur die File-Liste hat ziemlich sofort auf die NSA gezeigt, sondern der Sample Code war echt. Das war nicht sofort klar, weil man kann ja viel behaupten, aber es haben sich also Leute angesehen. Und da war also tatsächlich ein paar sehr hochkarätige und teure Zero-Days-Buy. Und daraufhin war also relativ schnell klar, die haben da das richtige Material. Also zumindest der Sample war echt. Und die Journalisten haben dann angefangen, die Bitcoin-Adresse zu überwachen, die die da angegeben hatten für ihre auktion. Und da kam aber irgendwie, kam dann nicht so richtig was zusammen. Es gab so ein paar Trolle.
Ja, es gab so einiges an, an so Leuten, die dann halt irgendwelche Messages in diese Bitcoin-Payments encoded haben, um irgendwie offenbar die Sachen zu kriegen und so. Na jedenfalls, dann gab es auch noch so, die haben das so gestaged, dass es halt immer wieder neue Sachen gab. Und die haben immer wieder ein paar Bits und Pieces released und so. Aber am Ende war halt diese, also der große Hammer war dann am 8. April diesen Jahres, das der sogenannte Don't Forget Your Base League.
Da haben sie einmal auf Release geklickt.
Genau, da haben sie halt das Passwort, ich glaube in der Medium-Post publiziert, zu dem Archiv, was ja schon alle hatten, was sie ja schon vorher publiziert hatten.
Ein langer Medium-Rant, also wenn man nicht der Ausdauer hatte, hätte man das Passwort auch nicht gesehen. Das heißt, es hat auch ein bisschen gedauert bis das irgendwie...
Und das Interessante daran war ja, dass sie so taten, als wären sie eine Gruppe von Trump-Unterstützern, die Trump jetzt noch mal darauf hinweisen, dass er irgendwie seine Versprechen einhalten sollte. Und es gab auch eine Referenz dazu, damals zu dem Trump-Angriff auf diesen syrischen Flughafen, der unter anderem auch von russischen Truppen genutzt wurde. Und die Story da drin war halt so, na ja, Trump, du musst dich an daran erinnern, was du versprochen hast, du willst keinen, da wird was versprochen, du fängst keine Kriege im Ausland an, du reist reitest uns nicht nochmal in irgendwelche Abenteuereien.
Es wirkte wie ein Wink mit dem Zaunfall von den Russen.
Genau, also dieses ganze Ding sah halt von Anfang bis Ende aus, wie als hätten die Russen das Zeug vorher auch schon langer Zeit gehabt und die NSA wusste wahrscheinlich, dass die Russen das hatten und also schon mindestens spätestens seit den Firelist wussten sie, was irgendwie weggekommen war und als hätten die Russen einen Weg gesucht halt zu signalisieren, dass sie die NSA sehr viel weiter infiltriert haben, als die NSA so glauben mag. Also es war halt eher so ein, also so Intelligenz-Kreisen heißt sowas, ein costly signal, also ein teures, ein teurer Weg, jemanden eine Nachricht zu schicken. Und so wurde es eigentlich so allgemein auch angenommen, dass es halt eigentlich im Wesentlichen die Russen waren oder jemand, der relativ glaubwürdigste tut, als wenn er irgendwie russische Interessen verfolgt.
Ja, man sollte aber noch dazusagen, was vielleicht von aus nicht so einfach zu sagen ist, die Feinliste sah schon so aus, als wenn es irgendwie einmal fast alles ist, was die NSA so hat. Also das war so dermaßen unglaublich viel, dass die Leute auch am Anfang alle gesagt haben, ach, das kann unmöglich stimmen. Und als dann dieses Passwort rauskam und da wirklich also generationen von Exploits gegen Ciske Ruta zum Beispiel einfach mal drin waren, also aber so einmal, also ich will nicht sagen alles, das weiß man ja nicht und es ist auch ein paar Jahre alt gewesen zu dem Zeitpunkt, aber das war wirklich ein massiver Schaden für die NSA. Das kann man nicht anders sagen. Und ein besonders großer Preis in diesem großen Cash war eben ein Exploit gegen Windows. Und zwar die schlimmste Art von Exploit, die es da gibt, nämlich über Netz. Und man kann am Ende Code ausführen auf dem Zielrechner. Und zwar als Kernel. Das ist also das allerhöchste Privileg, was man überhaupt haben kann im System.
Also der in Microsoft Parallel heißt es dann so Remote Code execution, Virmobile.
Genau. Virmobile ist so das Wort, das Microsoft, das Kriterium, was Microsoft nimmt, um zwischen High und Critical zu unterscheiden. Und das war also ein Critical.
Da gibt es nicht so viele von.
Und die kosten auch richtig Asche, wenn man sowas kaufen will auf dem Markt für ein Critical gegen Windows. Da ist schon mal, also siebenstellig kann zusammenkommen. Und dieses Ding war also nicht nur das Problem der Wormobile.
Lass uns mal Wormobile nochmal kurz erklären.
Wormobile heißt, dass man also ein Wurm schreiben kann, der das automatisiert ausnutzt und sich dann von der Kiste aus weiter verbreitet, ohne dass irgendjemand irgendwelche Parameter von Hand irgendwie justieren muss. Sondern das ist halt auch noch ein stabiler Exploit gewesen so weit. Und der funktioniert halt über generationen von Windows Systemen, die auch teilweise schon gar nicht mehr in Erwartung von Microsoft drin sind. Das war echt, also das war so das Schlimmste, was hätte liegen können. Und da haben schon alle Leute gesagt, oh mein Gott, was machen wir denn jetzt? Und es sah dann so aus, als ob Microsoft schon vorab erfahren hatte, dass der Exploit jetzt raus liegt. Denn sie haben irgendwie ein paar Tage vorher, 14. März haben sie ihren Patchtag erst kurz verschoben, kurz wusst ich. Und dann gab es halt einen Patch für dieses SMB-Link. Und da war also allen Beobachtern, die das gesehen haben, war klar so scheiße, das spielen wir sofort ein. So keine Verzögerung, das muss jetzt überall. So ist es scheißegal. Und das Problem war halt, dass sie den Patch nur für ihre supported windows-versionen rausgetan haben. Also das heißt zum Beispiel nicht Windows XP und nicht Windows Server 2003.
Bis wo geht Supported noch?
Ich glaube Windows 7 ist gerade das untere Ende von Supported. Das untere Ende. Und Windows 8.0 ist auch schon aus dem Support raus. Da muss man 8.1 haben. Okay. Also das war so, aber 8.0 will auch keiner haben. Das trifft jetzt nicht viele, aber Windows XP trifft wohl eine Menge Leute, weil das nämlich auch als embedded-version verkauft wurde, unter anderem für so Fahrkartenautomaten und wie wir bei der Bahn gesehen haben für Digital Signage, also so Anzeigetafeln.
Okay, gut, also nochmal kurz in der Timeline so. Microsoft hat so 14. März, haben sie offensichtlich ein paar Tage vorher Wind bekommen. Also die Theorie ist halt irgendwie, dass die NSA ihnen halt Bescheid gesagt hat, so Kinder, jetzt wäre guter Zeitpunkt zum Patchen.
Ja, also normalerweise hat Ransomware keine solchen Wurm-Dinger, sondern das war bisher immer was, was sich über E-Mail verbreitet hat. Wer die E-Mail klickt und auf das Attachement klickt, der hat halt eine Ransomware.
Also gab es schon so Verbreitungen, die dann das lokale E-Mail-Adressbuch benutzt haben, um E-Mails weiterzuschicken. Also so ein gewisser, das ist dann nicht Wurm, aber was ist dann wahrscheinlich irgendwas anderes. Also jedenfalls Exploits, die sich halt über E-Mail-Attachments verbreiten lassen. Und in der Regel war Ransomware sehr selten, tatsächlich mit einem solchen ODE, also mit einem ungepatchten Exploit. Also typischerweise ist die Ransomware, die so unterwegs ist, benutzt Exploits, die halt schon lange gepatcht sind und wo sie halt darauf hoffen, dass die Leute ihre Kisten nicht gepatcht haben, zu Recht meistens.
Also die Unterscheidung zwischen sich weiter ver-E-Mailen und Wormable ist, dass man bei E-Mail draufklicken muss und beim Worm hast du keine interaktion mehr, bevor der dich befällt. Es reicht, dass der mit dir redet und fertig. So, das heißt, das ist die, das sollte man vielleicht mal an dieser Stelle ganz klar sagen, das ist die Verteidigung, die eine Firma wie Microsoft aufbaut, um zu sagen, das ist nicht so schlimm, wenn da muss der User einmal draufklicken. Das ist so das Feigenblatt, hinter dem sich alle möglichen Sachen verstecken, nicht nur bei Sicherheit, sondern auch bei Datenschutz, dass die sagen, hör mal, es gibt hier eine Checkbox, da kannst du sagen, ich will keine Telemetrie zu Microsoft schicken und wer die nicht ausklickt, der hat zugestimmt. Ein Klick ist sozusagen das Feigenblatt. Und an dieser Stelle ist es eben so, dass es die erste Ransomware ist, die nicht nur einen Wurm als weiterverbreitungsfunktionalität drin hat, sondern auch noch einen derart hochqualitativen Wurm. Und der Lacher war, dass also diverse Security-Leute im April gesagt haben, als der Dump kam, na, das kann ja nur noch ein paar Wochen dauern, bevor eine Ransomware kommt. Und jetzt, das ist so ganz witzig bei den ganzen Leuten, die jetzt über diese Ransomware, den Wannacry, irgendwie ihre Analysen getweetet haben. Da ist dann immer oben der PIN-Tweet, ist dann der von irgendwie Mitte April, wo sie gesagt haben so, der Wurm wird kommen. Winter is coming.
Winter ist zu sagen, mit Ansage.
Also das Told you so ist gerade sehr groß in der Branche.
Ja, ich hatte doch so ein T-Shirt an.
Ja, also normalerweise, wenn man sich so eine Ransomware einfängt, hat man nicht so viele Chancen. Es gibt einige Ausnahmen, das sind aber Ausnahmen.
Also was man dazu vielleicht nochmal erklären muss, ist wie normalerweise halt so diese Ransomware-Ökosysteme funktionieren. Die sind normalerweise so aufgebaut, dass es eine Arbeitsteilung gibt zwischen den Leuten, die die exploit, meistens Ketten entwickeln, den Leuten, die die eigentliche Ransomware entwickeln, also die halt dann auf dem Computer halt die Falsch verschlüsselt und irgendwie den sozusagen dafür sorgt, dass der Nutzer nicht mehr rankam und den Leuten, die halt Kommat und Kontroll und die Zahlungsabwicklung machen. Das heißt also, die dann dafür sorgen, dass wenn der Nutzer sagt, er möchte jetzt zahlen, um den Schlüssel zu bekommen, dann dafür sorgen, dass er diesen Schlüssel auch bekommt. So normalerweise ist so ein hoch organisiertes Ökosystem aus verschiedenen arbeitsteiligen Gruppen.
Die alle mitverdienen.
Die alle mitverdienen und da gibt es dann so richtig Businessmodelle, wo so ein exploit oder exploit-chain halt verkauft wird oder vermietet wird, also wo gesagt wird, okay, wir hätten gerne so viel Prozent davon und dann gibt es halt noch so escrow-Systeme, die dafür sorgen, dass du, wenn du deinen exploit vermietet hast, dann auch dein Geld siehst, weil du vermietest ihn dann mit irgendwie Involvierung eines Payment-Providers, der dafür sorgt, dass die Bitcoins dann am Ende auch zum Teil bei dir landen und so.
Es gibt auch Spare-Messe-Service an der Stelle, dass du ein Botnetz mietest, was deine Payload verbreitet und die möchten dann auch pro return on investment gezahlt werden. Also da verdienen viele Leute mit und eine der großen Änderungen dieses Mal ist, dass wir mal tatsächlich die Bitcoin-Adressen beobachtet haben von diesem Monster.
Nee, es gab es tatsächlich schon vorher. Also wir wissen halt aus einigen anderen Ransomware-Kampagnen gibt es ja schon ganz gute Abschätzungen dafür, wie viel Geld die gemacht haben. Unter anderem dadurch, dass man halt diese Bitcoin-Adressen da halt rausgepupelt hat. Die cleveren haben teilweise pro infizierten User eine neue Bitcoin-Adresse, sich sozusagen abgeholt vom Server.
Aber auch mit logistischer Aufwand.
Nur wenn du halt einen Serverkommand, einen Kommand in kontrollkommunikationen läuft, meistens über Tor hast, dann kannst du sowas schon machen. Dann sagt das Ding halt hier ist mein Key, gib mir die Bitcoin-Adresse dazu. Ist nur doof, wenn in dem Augenblick der Nutzer den Stecker zieht, weil dann hat er vielleicht irgendwie, also dann ist er halt verloren. Na so in dem Augenblick, wo wenn er hektisch das Netz abklemmt, dann kann es halt sein, dass der Handshake nicht funktioniert. Das ist dann ein bisschen doof. Aber jedenfalls bisher war es halt so, dass viel von dieser Ransomware relativ guten Customer Service hatte. Also dass die halt schon dafür gesorgt haben, dass sich dieses Gefühl so, okay, wenn du so eine Ransomware einfängst, dann zahlst du halt, kriegst du deinen Key, hast du deine Daten wieder.
Hat sich auch funktioniert.
Hat im Schnitt relativ gut funktioniert, was halt auch dazu führte, dass dann halt auch die Behörden häufiger gesagt haben, so halt naja, zahl halt. Oder auch Heise hat es halt eine Zeit lang gesagt, dass irgendwie, wenn du es halt am Bein hast, und du brauchst deine Daten nicht dringend, dann kannst du warten, ob die einen Fehler gemacht haben in der Kryptoroutine und halt ein Key rumliegt oder der Key schlampig erzeugt ist oder sie halt die Krypto falsch verwendet haben, sodass es ein Decryptatool gibt. Das gab es häufiger mal, sodass dann halt so eine Woche oder zwei später halt Decryptatools auftauchten, nur wenn du deine Daten ganz dringend gebraucht hast, dann musstest du halt irgendwie zahlen.
Und dieser Ransomware hat eine Timebomb drin gehabt, wenn du nicht innerhalb von drei oder fünf Tagen oder so zahlst, wird es teurer, löst er deine Daten.
Ja, im Moment erst wird es teurer, erst verdoppelt sich der Preis und dann löst er deine Daten. Sie geben dir noch eine Chance.
Genau, also warten sollst du nicht. Die wissen schon, dass es ein Risiko ist.
Klar, ich meine, dieses Spiel mit der Psychologie des Nutzers, der plötzlich seine Daten nicht mehr hat, ist natürlich jetzt schon durch mehrere iterationen gegangen. Also da gibt es natürlich auch so einen gewissen Schatz an Erfahrungen darüber, wie man halt so was richtig macht. Interessant an dieser Ransomware ist halt, dass die halt für eine Ransomware relativ schlecht gemacht ist.
Also es gab schon Aspekte, die gut sind. Die Krypto zum Beispiel ist gut.
Die Krypto ist zum Beispiel gut, was darauf hinweist, dass da Profis am Werk waren, also die professional-kram gekauft haben.
Der Teil der Arbeitsteilung hat Profis genommen.
Also beim Exploit und bei der Krypto waren offenbar Profis am Werk. Beim Command & Control offenbar nicht so sehr. Da gab es dann diese Geschichte mit diesem sogenannten Key-Switch.
Ja, kommen wir gleich zu. Aber erstmal die Krypto. Wir können mal erzählen, wie die Krypto funktioniert. Der generiert tatsächlich einen RSA-Key lokal auf der Kiste aus echten Zufallswerten, benutzt auch das API, was man dafür benutzen soll und verschlüsselt den mit dem Public Key von dieser kriminellen organisation. Das heißt, ohne den Private Key von der organisation, und der ist nie auf dem Rechner gewesen, kommt man da nicht ran. Ja, und das ist ein 2048-Bit-Key. Das ist auch soweit nach Stand der Technik, kann man das vergessen. Insbesondere in der kurzen Zeit, aber auch ansonsten würde man sagen, vergiss das. Das heißt, auf Kryptoebene da was zu machen, das sieht im Moment nicht gut aus. Allerdings gibt es bei dieser Art von Ransomware inzwischen ja auch Leute, die oder so Mechanismen, um sich vor sowas zu schützen. Und eine davon ist eben, dass man so eine virtuelle Maschine hat und alle Mails einmal auf dieser virtuellen Maschine öffnet und guckt, ob die irgendwas Schlechtes tun. Um so zu erkennen, ob da ein Wurm drin ist. Und das heißt, viele, viele Mailware heutzutage hat irgendeinen Mechanismus, um zu erkennen, ob sie gerade in einer virtuellen Umgebung laufen oder nicht. Und auch dieser, diese Ransomware hat sowas. Und das war auf den ersten Blick nicht klar, was die funktionalität genau tut. Denn was die macht, ist nämlich eine URL aufrufen mit einer Domain, die aussieht wie Katze ist übers Keyboard gelaufen. Also eine Domain, die maximale Länge hat und nur aus Buchstaben aus den oberen beiden Keyboard-Zeilen besteht. Also es sieht aus wie, ich gebe hier mal was ein, was keiner registriert haben wird. Und in der Tat, die Domain gab es nicht. Und was jetzt häufig der Fall ist, in so virtuellen Maschinenumgebungen, ist, dass die HTTP-Zugriffe nach außen nicht zulassen, sondern alles abfangen und dann irgendwie eine leere Seite zurückgeben oder so.
Also du solltest mal erklären, diese virtuellen Maschinenumgebungen, die werden ja benutzt, um zu erkennen automatisch.
Ist das jetzt eine Mailware oder nicht?
Genau. Also das heißt, ganz viele Firmen haben halt solche Sachen installiert. Wenn die halt, zum Beispiel in ihrem E-Mail in Feed, so FireEye ist da so eine von den großen Firmen, die machen halt sowas, dass sie halt dann das Dokument in einer virtuellen Maschine öffnen und gucken, ob diese virtuellen Maschinen halt irgendwelche Dinge versucht, nach draußen zu tun. Und einer der einfachsten Tricks, um zu erkennen, dass du auf ein beziehungsweise in einer kontrollierten Umgebung als Mailware ausgeführt wirst, ist halt einfach erstmal eine HTTP-Verbindung nach außen aufmachen. Und zwar eine direkte HTTP-Verbindung nach draußen.
Also die FireEye und überhaupt solche Mechanismen gucken, denen ist eigentlich nicht so wichtig, was du mit dem Netz machst, sondern ob du lokal dich irgendwie in Autorans einträgst oder so. Ja, das heißt, was diese Ransomware machen wollte, ist, sie wollte gucken, laufe ich hier in so einer Umgebung und wenn ja, dann lasse ich mal den Rest weg. So in der Hoffnung, dass diese Umgebung dann sagt, okay, das ist keine, das sieht irgendwie okay aus und durchlässt. Ja, das heißt, es sah auf den ersten Blick aus wie ein Killswitch, denn das ist was passiert. Wenn man also diese Domain anmeldet und der hatte die PeriQuest, geht durch, dann glaubt dieser Trojaner, er läuft irgendwie in einer Umgebung von einem, entweder einem Mailware-Analyst, also jemand, der reverse-ingenieren will oder von so einer FireEye und schaltet, dann macht den Rest gar nicht. Das heißt, verschlüsselt dann auch nichts und macht auch kein Ransom und das heißt, irgendein, irgendein so ein Typ aus England hat diese Domain einfach gesehen, als er sich diese Ransomware angesehen hat und hat die angemeldet. Sehr früh am Tag, Tag eins, abends, hat er diese Domain gesehen, hat die mal eben angemeldet, weil er sich dachte, mal gucken, was passiert und hat die auf irgendeinen Blackhole umgeleitet. Das heißt, eine Kiste, die eigentlich nichts gemacht hat, außer eine Antwort geben und aber gucken, wer eigentlich mit ihm zu reden versucht und darüber gibt es also eine relativ gute Karte, wo die infektionen besonders verbreitet sind, weil aus den Ländern kamen dann eben die meisten Zugriffe auf diese Kiste und daher gibt es jetzt auch eine relativ neue Neuerung, praktisch für die interessierten Laien der Welt zu sehen. So eine schöne Karte, wie man sie aus Wargames kennt, wo dann so die ganzen kleinen grünen Kreise dahin gehen, wo gerade jemand infiziert wird. Das war eigentlich ganz witzig, dass man das mal sehen konnte. An sich muss man, also diese Dienste gibt es auch so, die muss man aber teuer kaufen und das nennt sich dann Threat Intelligence.
Na ja, also es gab es halt vorher auch schon mal, wenn es halt gelungen war, die Command- und Control-Kisten von so einer Mailware zu übernehmen.
Also bei wirklich großen Mailware-Dingern gibt es auch mal Anläufe. Aber dass es so früh gelingt, das hat es glaube ich noch nie gegeben.
Ne, und also typischerweise ist es dann halt so, dass die dann die Domains rausfinden. Also was halt diese Domains sind, die von der Mailware als Command- und Control-Signal benutzt werden. Und dann werden halt entweder die Domain-Provider sagen, dann halt wir rücken die halt raus oder große ISPs leiten diese Domains dann halt in ihren eigenen DNS-Servern um auf so eine Synchro-Server, die dann halt so von großen Antivirus-Buden betrieben werden. Das ist halt so ein relativ übliches Verfahren. Das heißt, wenn so eine Mailware eine gewisse Größe überschreitet, dass dann halt die Command- und Control-Domains dafür irgendwie unter Kontrolle gebracht werden oder die IP-Adressen sogar teilweise, wenn man mit statischen IP-Adressen geht, und dann...
und Control musst du noch erklären.
Command- und Control ist in der Regel für so eine Mailware ein wichtiges Element, nämlich das telefoniert zu ihrem Master. Das heißt, die machen halt eine Verbindung auf, worüber sie Kommandos entgegennehmen oder zum Beispiel den Key abliefern, mit dem sie die Festplatte verschüsselt haben, was in diesem Fall halt der, sozusagen die kernfunktionalität war, also dass sie halt...
Hatte er aber nicht gemacht. Das war ein anderer Kanal.
Genau. Das war ein anderer Kanal. Das haben sie in dem Fall über Tor gemacht. Oder halt auch zum Beispiel die Verbreitung zu kontrollieren. Oder bestimmte Stages von, was mache ich denn jetzt? Also wenn so eine Mail halt irgendwie verschiedene funktionsstages hat, nämlich erst mal Silent infection, macht halt nichts weiter als sich zu verbreiten, bis eine Verbindung zu einem bestimmten Domain durchgeht oder eine Verbindung zu einem bestimmten Domain eine bestimmte Antwort liefert. Erst dann macht sie zum Beispiel den Tor Command & Control Channel auf oder solche Sachen.
Was ist denn Tor?
Tor ist dieser Anonymisierungsdienst, der es ermöglicht halt übers Netz, ja, anonym zu kommunizieren, benutzt von irgendwie Freiheitskämpfern, oppositionellen Leuten, die sich vor Zensur schützen wollen, cyberkriminellen Geheimdiensten, also allen Leuten, die halt irgendwie an die kommunikation brauchen, auch gerne benutzt, um Drogen im Internet zu kaufen.
Genau, also früher war es so, Mensch redet mit Web-Server oder mit Chat-Server und inzwischen wird das auch für Maschine zu Maschine, kommunikation benutzt von irgendwelchen Kriminellen.
Genau.
Ja, und da kommen wir eigentlich schon zur ersten Frage, die wir hier auf der Liste haben, die wir mal ansprechen wollen, nämlich ob Bitcoin und Tor nicht die Enabler für so eine Art von Kriminalität ist, dass man nicht einfach sagen soll. Machen wir einfach aus.
Ja gut, natürlich ist es schon so, dass ohne ein digitales Zahlungsmittel wie Bitcoin wäre dieses ganze Ransomware-Business sehr viel schwieriger. Die ersten Ransomware-Kampagnen, die es gab, liefen über so was wie so Cashcards, die man so am kiosk kaufen kann.
Und iTunes-Giftkarten.
Genau, iTunes und Amazon-Geschenkkarten und sowas waren halt alle sehr mühsam und skalierte halt nicht so richtig. Also die Leute... Ja, pay safer. Genau, pay safer zum Beispiel war so ein Ding, was halt irgendwie über so was lief. Also skalierte aber nicht so richtig, also war halt auch... Deswegen die ersten Ransomware-Kampagnen, die halt wirklich richtig Durchschlag hatten, waren dann halt tatsächlich die, die wirklich die kombination von Bitcoin als Payment benutzt haben. Und ja, oder auch andere, es gibt ja noch jede Menge andere Coins, die dafür benutzt werden. Aber Bitcoin hat halt den großen Vorteil, dass es relativ einfach zu kriegen ist und...
Konvertibel ist.
Konvertibel ist. Also hat halt den großen Nachteil für die Ransomware-Leute, dass es halt treckbar ist. Man sieht ja halt alle Bitcoin-Payments, du musst dann halt noch so Bitcoin-Waschanlagen benutzen, um halt die Bitcoins da durchzukriegen, die dann halt auch Geld kosten. Jetzt gibt es aber eine neue generation von elektronischen, also Bitcoin-Nachfolgern, die, also also Zero-Cash zum Beispiel, die halt in den Payment-Prozess richtige Animmität eingebaut haben, wo dann halt dieses Tracking wegfällt. Da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, wenn die Ransomware-Leute entdecken, dass man damit sein Payment noch sehr viel besser abwickeln kann. Dann dürfte die Akzeptanz dieser Währung und der Kurs dieser Währung auch nochmal deutlich steigen. Interessant an diesem ganzen Ransomware-Ding ist aber eigentlich, dass es halt so eine Änderung des Business-Modells für Cybercrime war, also für Online-Kriminalität. Weil vorher war es ja so, wenn du so ein Botnetz hattest, was es ja schon lange gab, da gab es halt so eigentlich so drei wesentliche Anwendungsfüße. Das eine ist, du hast es für The North of South vermietet, also DDoS, wo du halt dann die Computer benutzt hast, um andere Computer abzuschießen. Das zweite war Werbebanner-Hajacking. Das heißt also, die haben dir halt in den Browser auf diesem Computer andere Werbung eingeblendet, als es normalerweise wäre und die dann halt verkauft. Und das dritte war halt...
Also indirekte Geldgewinnung jedenfalls.
Genau, und das dritte war halt noch eher schon noch ein bisschen mehr konsumerorientiert. Das war nämlich halt der Versuch dann halt über Account-Hajacking von zum Beispiel Online-Banking oder ähnlichen Sachen, wo man halt Geld mitmachen kann oder iTunes oder so. Oder Amazon halt irgendwie an das Geld oder an Ware zu kommen auf Kosten des Kunden. Und tatsächlich ist aber dieses Ransomware-Prinzip, also ein Kunde zahlt individuell für den Wiederzugang zu seinen Daten, ist quasi die Umstellung dieses Geschäftsmodells im digitalen Online-Kriminalitätsbereich von Business to Business. Nämlich ich vermiete ein anderes Business, mein Botnet-Metzwerk, zu Business to Consumer. Ich habe eine direkte payment-relationship mit meinem Kunden. So ich kann Upsale machen. Ich habe halt irgendwie Möglichkeiten, irgendwie der dynamischen Preis-Findung so. Also ist dann nämlich dieses, es wird halt teurer, länger du wartest. So du hast natürlich auch Probleme. Du brauchst...
Du kannst Lock-In machen.
Genau, du hast natürlich Probleme. Du brauchst nämlich zum Beispiel Customer Support, den du leisten musst. Aber letzten Endes, wenn man sich so anguckt, wer sind die wirklich reichen Leute auf diesem Planeten? Das sind halt sowas wie die Gebrüder Aldi oder der Besitzer von Walmart, die also Business to Consumer machen, weil sie halt nicht viel Geld von wenigen Leuten nehmen, sondern wenig Geld von ganz vielen Leuten. Und das haben dann... Dieses Geschäftsprinzip realisiert halt der Ransomware halt in einer sehr interessanten Art und Weise.
Und das heißt eben auch, dass Sicherheitslücken plötzlich auch an andere Leute als Geheimdienste verkauft werden könnten, ja? Bisher war es nämlich so...
Oder monetarisiert werden können, direkt.
Also der Markt für Sicherheitslücken war eigentlich weitgehend beschränkt auf irgendwelche Militärs- und Geheimdienste, die das eben für ihre bösen Zwecke haben wollten. Und jetzt kann man die auch...
Und Hersteller, die sie rechtzeitig vom Markt wegkaufen wollten.
Ja gut, aber das ist sehr... Also jetzt kann man sie auch direkt monetarisieren.
Genau, also damit dürfen also auch die Preise für Ransomware verwendbare Exploit-Chains deutlich gestiegen sein.
Gut, aber das Interessante jedenfalls an diesem Fall ist, dass die Leute, also auch die Presse angefangen hat, mal zu gucken, wie viel Bitcoins da eigentlich auffallen. Und wir sind inzwischen, ich glaube, bei 50.000 Dollar umgerechnet.
Ich hab jetzt gar nicht geguckt, aber es sind halt so relative Peanuts.
Das war heute Mittag. Also aber...
Ist auch nichts, also ist tatsächlich eine... Also unter Ransomware-Kampagnen in Gesichtspunkten äußerst unerfolgreiche, also wenig erfolgreiche Kampagne. So die erfolgreichen Ransomware-Kampagnen, wo man so ein bisschen tracken konnte, haben eher so einige millionen gemacht, pro Variante.
Da weiß man aber auch nicht, wie viel Rechner die infiziert hatten. Das ist so ein bisschen, was es schwer vergleichbar macht. Also wir haben hier Zahlen, aber so bei den üblichen Ransomwares weiß man eigentlich nicht, oder?
Nee, stimmt, man weiß es nicht so genau, aber man weiß halt, dass wirklich sehr viele Leute gezahlt haben und also gerade so die erfolgreicheren Sachen, die halt so auf der Basis von Visual Basic oder Office-Lücken und als infection Vector E-Mail-Attachment, die sich dann automatisch mit jeweils angepassten E-Mails ans Adressbuch verschickt haben oder teilweise so Sachen gemacht haben, wie hier das File, was ich dir vorhin geschickt habe, noch mal, diesmal ein heiles, war ja vorhin kaputt. Also so Sachen, also ein bisschen Intelligenz da.
Social Ransomware.
Social Ransomware, die waren halt brutal erfolgreich. Also die haben, die haben wirklich viel Geld eingesammelt.
Ich habe hier die Theorie, dass es so ein bisschen mit dem Schaden zu tun hat. Ja, wenn man, wenn man in den Nachrichten liest, dass es ein Cyber-Angriff ist, der 150 Länder erwischt hat, denkt man sich irgendwie, ach, das hat auch alle anderen erwischt. Ja, muss mir nicht peinlich sein, wenn ich sage, ich habe meine Daten verloren, weil ich von diesem Teil erwischt wurde. Aber wenn du nichts davon hörst, dann denkst du dir, du bist der Einzige, der so doof hat, darauf zu klicken und dann zahlst du lieber. Also das ist nur so eine Theorie, aber es könnte sein. Ja, also das ist spektakulär unerfolgreich auf der Seite der tatsächlich eingenommenen Gelder. Aber es ist spektakulär erfolgreich, wenn man sich die Anzahl der infizierten Rechner ansieht und dass die Zahlen überschlagen sich förmlich. Wir sind jetzt bei über 200.000 Rechner geschätzt.
Was selbst, naja, es hat auch für so die großen Botnetzzahlen jetzt wiederum auch nicht so spektakulär erfolgreich. Das ist halt so eine Oberklasse der großen Botnetz, aber jetzt nicht so in den Top 5.
Na, weil eben auch dieser Sandbox-Check sofort am ersten Tag gefunden wurde. Das war einfach ein Glücksfall. Allerdings gibt es in der Zwischenzeit auch Berichte von irgendwelchen security-installationen in großen Firmen, die generell, also das ist auch eine häufige Sache, wo man nur per Proxy rauskommt. Ja, und dieser Check benutzt extra nicht den Proxy. Ja, das heißt, es kann sein, dass, obwohl es diese Domain gibt, trotzdem in großen Firmen dieses Ding zwar versucht drauf zuzugreifen, und es gibt sie, aber weil er nicht bei den Proxy geht, kommt er nicht raus. Ja, das heißt, dass das jetzt nicht ausgestanden ist.
Und dann macht er seine infektion weiter.
Genau, macht einfach weiter seine infektion. Und es reicht ja, wenn einer durchkommt, wenn er sich per SNB mit diesem Wurm-Ding innerhalb des Netzes weiterverbreitet. Das ist ja ein Fehler, den viele Firmen machen, dass sie sozusagen sagen, ich habe hier außen meine Firewall und innen drin traue ich allen. Das ist eigentlich ein Rezept für Desaster. Und so spielt es sich auch ab. Und jetzt kam natürlich sofort die Frage, wer ist denn schuld? Wer ist denn schuld? Und Frank ist da zum Heute-Journal gegangen und hat gesagt, die NSN ist schuld, oder? Fasse ich das korrekt zusammen?
Das kann man so korrekt zusammenfassen, ja.
Ja, verteidige das doch mal. Aber warum ist denn die NSN schuld?
Naja, weil ich meine, gerade in diesem Fall lässt sich dieses Argument sogar sehr gut machen, weil dieser Exploit, auf dem haben die ja richtig viele Jahre gesessen. Also der ist halt schon so, also der ist in demselben Dump, in dem so Exploits für solaris-versionen, wo man irgendwie echt so in den Keller gehen muss, um noch irgendwie so eine alte KCD zu finden.
Ich hab noch ein Tape in meiner Antiquitätensammlung.
Heißt halt, dieser Exploit ist wahrscheinlich so alti Windows XP oder so. Das heißt also, der hat ja auch den schönen Namen Eternal Blue. funktioniert schon eine Weile. Der Code-Name weist darauf hin, dass das so in der Erbstückserie von Exploits ist. Heißt also, die selbstes Argument, die Patches sowieso ihrer alten Windows-Maschinen viel zu selten, zählte einfach nicht, weil dieser Exploit einfach so alt ist. Die sitzen da seit vielen, vielen Jahren drauf. Und das heißt also, wenn die irgendwann mal beschlossen hätten, okay, selbst wenn wir sonst Exploits für uns behalten, denn Critical Vormeble, in so einer großen installierten Basis, so den muss man einfach, also da gibt es kein Argument dafür, den irgendwie weiter geheim zu halten. So und worauf das halt hinweist für mich, ist halt, dass dieser gesamte Prozess, wo die halt sagen, okay, wir entwickeln Exploits, und die benutzen wir dann, um irgendwie böse Terroristen zu fangen oder was auch immer sie dann irgendwie als Entschuldigung haben, andere Länder auszuspionieren. Wenn sie da halt irgendwas haben, mit dem sie halt irgendwie über einen USB-Stick einen Rechner in einem Hotelzimmer exploiten können. Das ist was, wo man sagen kann, ich finde das immer noch verkehrt, ich finde das immer noch verwerflich, aber ich könnte zumindest das Argument akzeptieren, dass man sowas als Geheimdienst manchmal braucht. Ja, also das ist halt so ein Risiko, sowas für sich zu behalten, versus irgendwie einen Critical Vomit, für sich zu behalten, ist halt eine völlig andere Klasse.
In beiden Fällen geht es zu Lasten von uns allen, das wollen wir mal festhalten.
Genau, in beiden Fällen geht es zu Lasten von uns allen.
Die Leittragenden sind immer wir, die Konsumenten.
Ja, na und vor allen Dingen, wenn man sich mal überlegt, was die ja selber auf verwundbaren Systemen fahren. Ich meine, es gibt da draußen sowas wie Windows for Warships und Windows for Submarines und das ist kein Scherz. Also das ist halt die Fahnder wirklich ihr Militärgerät mit.
Die britische Zweitschlagsabwehr, Abwehrwaffe, Windows for Submarines, und zwar Windows XP. Aus Kostengründen, damals gab es schon Neuress, aus Kostengründen haben sie XP genommen.
So und dass die selbst unter diesen Umständen so einen Bug für sich behalten. Und es gibt in Amiland ja diesen sogenannten Vulnerability Equities Process, was halt theoretisch der von der obama-administration und gerade die vom Anfang so eingeführte Prozess sein sollte, wo die Ganze sagen, okay, wir haben jetzt irgendwie diesen Exploit und das ist halt das, was wir damit anrichten können. Und wir würden gerne mal drüber reden, ob und wenn ja wie groß das Risikoprofil für die Regierung und die Öffentlichkeit ist, ob wir den behalten können oder ob wir den melden sollen.
Kam aber auch nicht, weil Obama so ein freundlicher Mensch ist, sondern weil es einen massiven Aufschrei gab, dass die Exploits kaufen. Und dann war so das Feigenblatt, ach guck mal, wir machen hier mal diesen Prozess und jetzt können wir sehen, was davon zu halten war, nämlich nicht.
Genau, also die haben da halt einfach mal auf Deutsch gesagt, wie schissen, das war halt irgendwie so ein Schutzbehaupt. Das hat halt genauso gut funktioniert wie bei uns die g10-kommission. Die Geheimdienstaufsicht funktioniert halt genau nach dem Motto, wenn die Geheimdienste kommen und sagen, wir hätten da mal was.
Wenn sie freiwillig ihre Sünden beichten, dann haben wir eine Chance zur Aufklärung und selbst die wird nicht genommen.
Genau. Und genauso funktioniert halt dieser Rollability-Acquities-Process, also genau gar nicht. Und diese Dreistigkeit, wenn wir jetzt von irgendwas reden würden, was irgendwie Systeme, wo man sagen kann, okay, das ist jetzt nicht so ein gigantisches Risiko. Und das ist so, denn FANNIC IT immer noch verwerflich, weil aus prinzipiellen Gründen der Meinung bin, die sollten so etwas nicht tun. Aber das wäre bei weitem nicht in diesem Skalierungsfaktor, wo man quasi, na ja, wenn man jetzt mal analogweltinstruktionen bzw. Analogien ziehen lassen will, fällt mir da keine Sinnvolle ein, weil die halt irgendwie alle nicht passen. Microsoft faselt irgendwas von Tomahawks, aber das ist halt irgendwie auch Unsinn, ja.
Na ja, das ist wie, also ich finde, eine gute Analogie ist, es gibt so einen Stockpile von Smallpox, den die Yamis aufheben. Mit dem, also eigentlich haben, ja, eigentlich haben wir Pocken ausradiert, aber es gibt noch einen Stockpile so für, falls man das mal braucht. Und da gibt es eigentlich auch keine, da kann man sich echt aus dem Fenster lehnen, es gibt keine Begründung, die irgendwie gutartig wäre, außer wir wollen damit irgendwann die Russen vergasen. Ja, so es gibt einfach nichts, was man davor bringen könnte. Das ist einfach nur bösartig. Und ja, so ist das halt mit Regierung, muss man einfach mal sagen. Jedes Mal, wenn wir denen irgendwas glauben sollen, stellt sich dann wenig später raus. Hätten wir lieber nicht geglaubt.
So, das ist halt der eine Aspekt. Der andere Aspekt ist natürlich, also ich hab die gegenposition vertreten, muss ich mal sagen. Und auch die gegenposition ist natürlich valide, nämlich, äh, hallo Microsoft, ist doch jemand zu Hause?
Das hat mich echt geärgert, dass der Microsoft-Präsident, oder was, wer war das? Der Justizia, der auch gleichzeitig irgendwie, ist ja egal, jedenfalls jemand hohes in der organisation, hat sich da aus dem Fenster gelehnt und eine position vertreten, so. Ja, also man sieht hier die Risiken davon, dass Geheimdienste offensive Exploits kaufen. So, als wenn das jetzt Schuld der NSA wäre. Ja, aber so, als wenn es jetzt schuld der NSA ist, dass es da einen SMB-Bug gibt, ja, den hätte ja auch Microsoft finden können, der ist, also ich sag mal zehn Jahre alt, ja, hätte man ja finden können. Aber, also, haben sie es sich ja auch versucht, aber haben sie halt nicht gefunden. Und das...
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Ja, das ist...
Du kennst den da nur so ein bisschen.
Ja, ich hab sogar mal in den SMB-Code geguckt. Ah, der SMB-Code ist leider groß und verteilt, insofern hab ich nicht den SMB-Code gesehen. Aber, also, es könnte theoretisch sein, dass ich diesen Bug nicht gesehen hab. Das kann ich nicht völlig ausschließen, weil ich nicht weiß, was der genau...
Also du hast den Bug jetzt noch nicht angeguckt?
Ich hab den... Nein. Also ich hab das als Policy, dass ich mir diesen Shadow-Broker-Kram nicht runterlade, weil sonst gibt's irgendwann Fragen, wenn ich irgendwo einreisen will. Deswegen... Also das ist ein Risiko, was ich mir persönlich einfach nicht geben will, da irgendwann von irgendwelchen Schlipsträgern befragt zu werden oder Schlapphüten. Insofern, ich weiß es nicht. Aber es ist natürlich nicht einfach, so eine Bugs zu finden, aber man kann es tun. Das ist mit Aufwand verbunden, kostet Geld. Und das SMB alt und gammlig ist, also das kann echt keiner behaupten, das nicht gewusst zu haben. Insofern fand ich das sehr billig, sich da jetzt hinzustellen und zu sagen, ja, die böse böse NSA hat hier irgendwie Stockpiles. Ja, auf der dritten Seite hat mich auch sehr geärgert, jetzt hier zu sagen, unsere armen Kunden, wenn hier von der NSA irgendwie ins Risiko gezogen, denn die armen Kunden hatten zwei Monate Zeit, diesen scheiß Patch einzuspielen, an dem dran stand Wormable Critical und sie haben es nicht getan. Und da hab ich dann überhaupt keinen Mitleid, muss ich euch sagen.
Andererseits...
Die patch-version ist nicht ganz einfach, das wollen wir jetzt auch noch mal ein bisschen erläutern, aber ich hab da keinen Mitleid, tut mir leid. Wenn da dransteht Wormable, dann ist einfach mal egal, ja. Auch wenn die produktion runterfährt, ist es weniger schlimm, als wenn ich ein Wormable-Attack-Surface habe irgendwo.
Vielleicht benutzen die ja niemand.
Ja, na klar. Sieht man ja, wie toll das funktioniert. Gut, also was ist denn so schwierig am Patchen, erzähl uns das doch mal. Warum haben die Leute noch altes Windows?
Also ist das so eine Frage, die mich halt schon seit einer Weile bewegt, weil ich bin ja häufiger in der Industrie unterwegs und sehe da halt auch, was da so rumsteht und passiert, was die Leute so benutzen so.
Man sollte vielleicht sagen, wir sind hier in der Raumfahrtagentur und man muss gar nicht so weit laufen, bis zur Industrie, um da halt eine installation zu suchen.
Also tatsächlich ist irgendwie so der der nächstgelegene alte Windows-PC steht hier auf der Treppe und der betreibt unseren Laser-Cutter. Und diese Software für diesen Laser-Cutter ist halt so ein China-Laser-Cutter. Und wir haben halt schon ganz lange auf der müsste man mal Liste, den ja da muss doch eigentlich mal irgendwie, müssen wir den nochmal mit freier Software betreiben. Tatsächlich ist die Realität aber, es gibt da eine funktionierende Windows-Software, ich weiß gar nicht, was wir da haben, 2000 vielleicht oder so. Ja, ja, ist richtig alt.
Vor XP noch?
Nee, ne, wahrscheinlich XP sein, ist ein XP wahrscheinlich. Ja, ist ein XP. Aber jedenfalls, die Software sieht aus, als wäre sie für 2000 geschrieben worden. Das ist glaube ich ein XP. So und diese Software redet halt über ein super kryptisches Protokoll mit diesem Laserdrucker. Und naja, man müsste jetzt halt, um das richtig zu machen, müsste man halt irgendwie so ein paar Teile in der Hardware austauschen, also in der Controller-Hardware, müsste da vielleicht mal irgendwie einen Raspberry einbauen, da halt irgendwie den ganzen Steuerviertelkram da irgendwie auf diesen Raspberry umbiegen, dann halt irgendwie ein Stück Software auf diesen Raspberry portieren, die halt dafür sorgt, dass halt die XY-Ansteuerung und Leistungssteuerung von dem Laser funktioniert und so weiter. Also es ist halt schon eher so ein Projekt für mehr als einen Nachmittag. Und naja, und was wollen die Leute machen, die hier sind? Die wollen halt einfach mal lasern. Also sie wollen halt einfach nur nichts weiter als irgendwie mal irgendwie sich einen File auf den USB-Stick gruppieren, zu diesem Rechner gehen, den da reinstecken, den File wieder laden, importieren und die auf Laser mal drücken.
Wo habt ihr den denn her?
Den haben wir von irgendeiner, einem China-Importer gekauft.
Neu?
Ja.
Ach, im neuen China-Scheiß ist noch ein Windows XP drin? Also was heißt denn jetzt neu, wie lange haben wir den?
Den haben wir jetzt so sechs Jahre, glaube ich, fünf Jahre, sechs Jahre, so was. Ja, nee, ist schon so gut, so.
Hocharomatisch.
Wenn du dieselbe Kiste heute kaufst, ist da immer noch nichts drauf. Nein, ist nicht drauf. Da kommt halt ein Stück, einen Dongle mit dabei, also so ein USB-Stick mit irgendwie einem Magic-File und da ist dann halt diese Software drauf, die du dann halt auf deinem Computer installierst und die, ja, die funktioniert halt. Also das Ding ist halt nicht networkt, sondern ist halt offline. Aber dann sind wir so clever, weil wir dachten uns, wir wollen jetzt...
Das haben sich die Iraner auch gedacht.
Aber es ist tatsächlich ein schönes Beispiel dafür. Also es funktioniert genauso, wie es halt in der richtigen Industrie auch funktioniert. Weil genau, was ich gerade erzählt habe, genau diese Dinge hast du auch, wenn du halt zum Beispiel so eine CNC-Maschine betreibst. Wenn du die gekauft hast, so irgendwie, sagen wir mal, sechs, sieben Jahren oder so, die ist ja noch gut.
Das schreibt man ab über, sagen wir mal, 30 Jahre, oder?
Ja, so ist ja eine richtige Werkzeugmaschine. Die kostet irgendwie zwei millionen und irgendwie war richtig teuer und die tut halt ihren Job. Und da dran klemmt halt so ein PC mit irgendwie so einem 800 x 600 Display. Und irgendwie kannst du dann halt irgendwie deinen Pfeil laden und noch ein bisschen angucken und manipulieren, die Parameter einstellen und auf Go drücken. So und in diesem PC steckt dann halt irgendwie wahrscheinlich eine Schrittmutteransteuerungskarte oder irgendwie so eine GPIO, PCIe Expresskarte oder so.
Wir sollten das mal alles erklären. Weil ich glaube, das Problem ist, also aus dem persönlichen Erfahrungshorizont unserer Hörer würde ich jetzt mal vermuten, wenn ihr einen uralten Netscape-Navigator ladet von 1999 und der tut den heute auf dem Windows, dann geht der noch. Also sobald man damit eine Webseite lädt, crasht er dann, weil das alte Scheiße ist, die Software.
Aber dein Blog könnte man damit noch klicken.
Aber man kann, genau, also so einfache Webseiten kann man auch. Die Software funktioniert prinzipiell. Wie kommt denn das, dass jetzt diese China-Software auf dem neueren Windows nicht tut? Woran scheitert denn das konkret?
Also tatsächlich habe ich diese Software noch nicht auf dem neueren Windows ausprobiert, was damit zu tun hat, dass hier niemand Windows tut. Und wie sagt das denn? Never touch a running system.
Ich kann mit diesen Apple-Leuten immer mit ihrem fadenscheinigen Ausreden.
Na ja, wenn, dann würden wir das richtig machen und dann ordentlich Linien drauf tun und so weiter. Aber letzten Endes, also das ist halt der eine Pfad, der geht ja. Warum soll ich es anfassen? Es funktioniert. Meine Erfahrung ist, wenn ich es anfasse, hört irgendwas auf zu funktionieren. Das ist ja die Erfahrung, die Menschen mit Computern haben. Ja. Also dann musst du dich da wieder hinsetzen und wochenlang frickeln, damit du den Status von vorher erreichst. Nur dafür, dass es jetzt irgendwie ethisch reine Open-Source-Software ist. Mit dem Nachmittag kann man auch was besseres anfangen.
Übrigens, diese Ransomware, Wannacry, funktioniert in Wine. Das ist der Windows-Immulator, den es für Linux gibt, in dem nichts läuft außer diese Ransomware. Die funktioniert und Notpad oder so. Notpad und ich glaube, mein Sweeper geht auch.
Na die wichtigen Sachen. Solitär wahrscheinlich auch.
Ich glaube, Solitär hat so ein paar Effekte. Diese Ransomware funktioniert in dem Immulator.
Gut, also nehmen wir mal einfach so eine CNC-Fräse. Das kann man sich wieder gut vorstellen. Das ist halt so eine große Maschine, die als einen Fräskopf durch die Gegend bewegt, wo man halt so große Starkplätze mitfräsen kann. Und die besteht halt aus einer großen Kiste. Und da sind halt sehr viele Motoren verbaut. Und diese Motoren müssen angesteuert werden. Und die müssen relativ präzise angesteuert werden, weil du willst ja mit deiner Fräse auf einem 100mm genau fräsen. So und aus dieser Anforderungen resultieren halt bestimmte Hardware-Anforderungen. Und die werden meistens abgedeckt mit spezialisierten Einsteckkarten. Also da gibt es dann halt entweder so Einsteckkarten direkt in den PC oder es gibt noch mal so ein separates Kontroller-Unit, wo halt die Motortreiber drin sind, die dann wiederum aus dem PC gesteuert werden über eine PCI-Karte, wo du halt ganz viele Anschlüsse hast, die du halt irgendwie auf entweder mit einem, also wie auf so einem Arduino, kann man sich so vorstellen, das was du auf einem Arduino habt, so Digital-IoA-Ausgänge oder halt irgendwie Analog-Ausgänge, gibt es halt auch noch mal so ein so Industrie-PC als Einsteckkarte.
Also GPIO hätte man früher gesagt, man schließt es an den Drucker-Port an.
Parallelport, genau.
Parallelport, denn da konnte man sozusagen, jeder Pin war ein eigenes Bit und man hat irgendwie sowas geschrieben wie ein Word, 16 Bit. Und jedes Bit in dem Word, was man geschrieben hat auf den Port, kam dann halt bei einem Pin an. Und die Geschwindigkeit, in der man geschrieben hat, hat eben dazu geführt, dass sich das Signal entsprechend ändert. Und was jetzt diese Stepper-Motoren und CNC-Maschinen machen, ist, dass sie Echtzeitanforderungen haben, nennt sich das. Das heißt, ich muss dann aber auch in sehr kurzen und sehr präzisen Zeitabständen reagieren. Und das würde man, wenn man es richtig macht, so machen, dass man über, sagen wir mal, ein USB oder irgendwas, von mir aus auch Ethernet, da einen Stream hingibt, wo drin steht, das ist hier die Timing-Anforderung zu diesem Zeitstempel, tu das. Das macht man aber nicht.
Genau. Und dann bräuchte man halt noch einen zweiten Computer.
Dann bräuchte man einen kleinen Arm, der einfach an diesem Ding dran ist.
Oder einen Dicken, je nachdem wie groß die Maschine ist.
Ja, oder halt mehrere. Aber weißt du, so ein Arm kostet was.
Heutzutage, ne?
Ja, gut. Aber der Punkt ist jedenfalls, diese zeitkritische Ansteuerung ist eben damals, und das wird auch heute noch von einigen Furschern so gemacht, nicht auf der Kiste selber gemacht worden, sondern man sagt, das muss der PC machen, der das Ding steuert. Ja, und da hat man jetzt aber so eine Probleme wie, dass Windows eben also mehr als einen Benutzer theoretisch kann, oder mehr als eine Software gleichzeitig laufen lassen kann. Das heißt, wenn ich sage, ich möchte irgendwie in fünf Millisekunden möchte ich wieder geweckt werden, um diese aktion zu machen, dann kann es einfach sein, dass Windows in der Zwischenzeit irgendwie, was weiß ich, auf Platte swappt oder irgendwas anderes tut, und ich werde zwar geweckt, aber ein bisschen später. Und das ist normalerweise kein Problem, aber wenn ich einen Snapper-Motor anschreiben will, ist das ein Problem. Und nun sagt Windows, keine Zusage von wegen Echtzeitfähigkeit. Das heißt, das unter irgendeiner version von Windows zu machen, ist eigentlich ein Risiko, was man nicht eingehen sollte.
Es gibt also Windows echtzeitextensions, nur diese ADX inter-extensions, die du dir halt dazu kaufen kannst, von Social-Party-Herstellern, wo ich mich immer frage, was tut die da eigentlich?
Was tut die da eigentlich? Also der Punkt ist jedenfalls, Echtzeit mit Windows ist sehr schwierig bis unmöglich, sollte man eigentlich generell nicht machen, aber die Leute haben es halt trotzdem gemacht und haben dann gesagt, pass auf, wir machen hier so eine Karte rein und da kannst du die Bits wieder einzeln kippen, an die hinten dann in Stepper-Motor gehen. Diese Hardware ist halt irgendwie Custom, Spezial, der Neffe vom CEO irgendwo in Auftrag gegeben, keine Ahnung, aber das ist jedenfalls nichts, was man bei Amazon oder im Elektro-Laden kaufen kann, sondern das ist halt ein Spezial-Ding und da braucht man dann eben auch einen Treiber für. Und diesen Treiber haben die halt geschrieben und nicht signiert, weil sie irgendwie 100 Kunden haben oder was und haben sich gesagt, okay, irgendwie so einen Treiber zu signieren, kostet 100 Euro.
Die schippen die Maschinen sowieso selber, das heißt, die gesamte installation auf dieser Kiste kommt eh von uns.
Und bei Windows, wenn man halt einen unsignierten Treiber installieren möchte, dann sagen ältere versionen von Windows, das ist aber total unsicher, willst du das wirklich machen? Und wenn, dann sagst du halt ja, so als Hersteller. Das heißt, der Hersteller hat vorher schon gesagt, ja, ja, das ist ein Risiko, was ich eingehen will und schippt dir den Rechner mit vorinstalliertem Treiber. Und das hat Microsoft irgendwann geändert, also nicht bei allen windows-versionen und auch nur bei 64-Bit wirklich, aber inzwischen gibt es diesen, ja, ich weiß, was ich tue, lass mich mal machen, Knopf nicht mehr. Da muss man Windows dann mit einem speziellen Parameter booten und sagen, ich bin hier Developer und ich darf testen. Also es gibt immer noch Wege drumherum, aber wenn man die einschaltet, steht unten rechts in der Ecke, Achtung, das ist ein Developer-Bild, nicht für produktion benutzen. Ja, und das tut sich halt schlecht. So, daher haben viele von diesen Herstellern irgendwann entschieden, ok, also die neuere windows-version supporten wir halt nicht. Ja, das ist alles, da gibt es keinen rationalen Grund für, das ist einfach...
Na gut, es gibt halt noch andere Gründe. Also eine davon ist, dass halt viel von dieser Software in solchen Buden, die halt lange Produktzüge drin haben, ist halt sehr tradiert. Also die haben halt häufiger mal relativ viel Software, die...
Das ist ein Euphemismus....
Software, die...
Brauchtumspflege....
die halt von Leuten geschrieben wurde, die schon wirklich lange nicht mehr da sind, die halt häufiger halt eben auch keine richtig fortgestimmten Software-Entwickler waren, sondern halt...
E-Techniker.
Ja, oder halt...
Es ist so, das Schimpfwort unter Informatiker ist immer der E-Techniker, der versucht, dir noch ein Bit zu sparen.
Oder halt Maschinenbauer, die halt irgendwie zu dem Zeitpunkt, als halt irgendwie CNC-Maschinen anfingen billig zu werden, halt eigentlich irgendwie dahin kamen, um halt irgendwie CNC zu bauen und dann halt plötzlich die Software dafür schreiben mussten. Weil sie möglicherweise auch die Einzigen waren, die Domain-Knowledge hatten, die wussten, wie man halt so eine Fräseanstellung macht. Man muss ja überlegen, wenn du so eine CNC-Maschine baust, dann willst du dich nicht darum kümmern, was jetzt irgendwie mit dieser doofen Treibersignatur ist, sondern du willst sicherstellen, dass dein gottverdammter Fräser auf ein Tausendstel Millimeter irgendwie mit der richtigen Drehzahl an der richtigen Stelle ist. Das ist halt so der... Du hast andere prioritäten. Du willst halt... Du baust ja eigentlich keine Software, denkst du dir so.
Und ähnlich sieht es auch im Medizinbereich aus und in Laborgeräten. Die denken sich alle, ach komm, das ist hier ein Ultraschall oder was weiß ich. Ist ja auch egal, letztendlich, was für ein Gerät es ist. Aber es ist ein Gerät und der Software-Teil wird als Gimmick betrachtet. Das ist zwar irgendwie auch wichtig für die funktionalität, aber was wir hier... Wir sind hier keine Software-Firma. Wir sind eine Medizin-Geräte-Firma. Wir bauen Ultraschall, nicht Software. Also das Selbstbild ist so, dass die Leute einfach sagen, pass auf, das ist hier nicht unser Job, uns um irgendwelche Windows-Minutes zu kümmern.
Und ihre Erfahrung ist, in dem Moment, wo sie anfangen, zum Beispiel Windows abzudaten, hören Dinge auf zu funktionieren.
Ja, und das kostet einfach Geld und dem steht kein...
Nutzen entgegen....
kein wirtschaftlicher Nutzen entgegen.
Also es ist kein unmittelbarer. Also sie haben halt nichts davon, außer dass sie einen schnelleren PC brauchen, weil das Windows halt langsamer wird, wenn sie so... heißt halt irgendwie, dass sie den Leuten einen Hardware-Upgrade für den Computer...
Das ist eine üble Nachrede von Apple.
Ist das so, ja? Ich weiß nicht, ich sehe bei den PC-Freunden immer nur neue Hardware kaufen, weil sie sagen...
Ach, die Apple-Leute nicht?
Entschuldigung, dieser Computer ist irgendwie ein drei Jahre altes Design und fährt aktuelle Software, wie es ist. Na ja, bei dir da ist er immer zu der Lüfte an, das hört man doch schon hier.
Ja, ja.
Aber jetzt kannst du dich damit rausreden, dass du Klinik gebootet hast.
Also es ist jedenfalls ein grundsätzliches Problem, dass viele Hersteller einfach sich überhaupt nicht gedürtigt sehen, dann Aktuelles Windows zu supporten, weil einfach Safety und Security als verschiedene Paar Schuhe gesehen werden. Ja, also wenn das Gerät Feuer fängt, dann halten sie sich für zuständig. Aber wenn das Gerät an einem Botnet teilnimmt, dann halten sie sich nicht für zuständig.
Na ja, und dazu kommt jetzt halt natürlich, dass die Anforderungen sich ja geändert haben. Also das ist ja so, dass der, das früher... Ja, und zwar ganz viele von diesen Geräten sind ja nur, sagen wir mal, früher stand auf so Fernsehendorf so HD ready, was eigentlich bedeutete, dass man sich trotzdem neuen Fernseher kaufen musste. Und diese ganzen Geräte sind ja so network ready.
Ja, aber immer noch. Ist auch immer noch total kurz, was du kriegst heutzutage.
Nee, aber wenn du hast da so ein Laborgerät oder so eine CNC-Maschine, da ist halt so ein Ethernet-Port dran gewesen, weil der war halt an dem PC dran.
Inzwischen ist ein Wi-Fi-Port dran.
Und das XP kann halt irgendwie auch irgendwie IP, wenn man es irgendwie dazu zwingt. So und das hat aber nie jemand benutzt, bis halt, also tatsächlich war der Standard lange in den Werkhallen immer noch USB-Sticks und ist teilweise immer noch. Und die Maschinen waren also effektiv offline lange. Und dann sind die halt irgendwann vernetzt worden, um es halt alles schneller zu machen, um halt die produktionsdaten besser kontrollieren zu können und so weiter, sind die halt ans Netzwerk gekommen. Und dann passieren halt so Sachen wie irgendwie vor einer Weile, als ich irgendwie auf so einer Besichtigung in so einer Werkhalle war. Und ich schiel das aus dem Augenwinkel rüber und das ist ganz schön bunt und denke mir, das sieht aber nicht aus wie dieses komische CNC-Interfaces, weil die sind normalerweise immer so mintgrau. Und dann bin ich da einfach mal rübergelaufen zu dem Typen, so dachte ich, was zockst denn da, so und dann meinte, ja Warcraft. Und dann hatte er tatsächlich die Eide-CNC-Maschine, auf der ein relativ neuer PC war, der halt irgendwie mehr als 800 mal 600 hatte. Und hat dann halt Warcraft drauf gezockt, weil die Maschine hat halt Internet, weil er hatte ziemlich lange Wartezeiten zwischendurch, wo man darauf passen musste, dass die Maschine nicht irgendwie kaputt geht. Und noch viel Kraft.
Da hab ich neulich ne Anekdote gehört. Da ging es um Firmen, die versucht haben, intern im Netz Pornos zu blocken. Ja und die Anekdote geht also so in großen Firmen, dass ne Firma das ungefähr ne Woche durchhält. Und dann schläft ihnen immer die Nachtschicht ein. Weil die nix zu tun haben in der Nachtschicht. Die sollen halt da stehen und gucken, dass die Maschinen nicht Feuer fangen. Und das ist irgendwie nicht menschenmöglich, das durchzuhalten, wenn man nicht Pornos hat. Offensichtlich jedenfalls so nach einer Woche kommt dann irgendwie der Schichtleiter an und sagt, ey pass auf, mach doch mal ne Ausnahme. Wenigstens nachts. Weil das wird dann üblicherweise irgendwie mit, wir haben ja auch Kinder, die uns besuchen, begründet. Und das gibt's halt nachts nicht. Und dann so, komm, komm, ist nachts. Lass uns Bordel gucken.
Also genau dieselbe Sparte fällt halt der, was so Leute, die in so Firmen arbeiten, diese Browser Games machen. Also ihr kennt ja diese Browser Games. Und vielleicht habt ihr euch schon mal gewundert, warum die immer so in der Mitte vom Schirm auf effektiv so was wie 800 x 600 Screen Size laufen. Und Browser Games, die Fullscreen laufen, auch immer auf relativ kleiner Auflösung skalierebar sind und trotzdem noch gut funktionieren. Na ja, ist ganz klar, die Leute wissen ziemlich genau, wie diese Browser Games programmieren, was für Bildschirmauflösungen ihre User halt klicken. Und die haben einen nicht ganz unerheblichen Anteil an Leuten, die halt vor solchen Maschinen stehen und darauf dann halt Browser Games klicken, bis die Maschine beep sagt und sie dann halt fertig sein muss.
Ja, also übrigens, wer sich denkt, irgendwie ohne Ethernet heißt ohne Netz, der kann sich mal auf Wikipedia durchklicken. Zum einen ein Stichwort wäre zum Beispiel Fieldbus. Oder also es gibt da diverse irgendwelche Industrienetzwerkverbindungsgeschichten. Und das ist natürlich alles schon immer unsicher gewesen. Also lasst euch da mal nichts einreden. Es hing halt nicht am Internet. Oder man wusste zumindest nicht, dass es am Internet hängt.
Es hing halt direkt am Internet, sondern es gab halt ein Fieldbus-Gerät.
Also inzwischen ist es heute so, dass die Geräte direkt WLAN sprechen. Und ich habe so ein paar Anekdoten gehört von Leuten, die halt ihre Laborgeräte anschalten. Und dann stellen sie fest, dass sie sich von alleine ins WLAN einklären. Es ist nichts, was du anschaltest, sondern du machst das Gerät an und das Gerät sucht sich dann ein offenes WLAN und geht da rein. Und das ist an Unis dann eben so das Gast-WLAN nach dem Motto. Das heißt, die sind automatisch verwundbar, wenn du nichts tust. Das ist nichts, was du irgendwie versäumt hast, sondern von sich aus sind die einfach im Netz. Und das haben viele noch nicht so auf den Blick. Und das Problem ist auch, dass viele Geräte Netzanschluss brauchen, weil sie darüber irgendwelche Lizenzscheiße abfragen.
Oder Support. Also es ist halt tatsächlich auch ganz häufig so, dass...
Ja, wobei Support kann man auch argumentieren. Das schließe ich erst an, wenn ich Support brauche. Und ansonsten muss nicht.
Das kannst du in dem produktionsenvironment eigentlich kaum argumentieren. Also ich kenne zum Beispiel einen Hersteller von so wirklich großen Werkzeugmaschinen, die ja so richtig teuer sind und ziemlich spezialisiert. Und da war es halt so, da hab ich halt gefragt so, naja, wie macht ihr das denn? Die haben ja auch alle Netz, die Maschinen und so. Warum? Und die meinten so, ja, weil wir den Support anbieten, dass wenn Kunden Probleme haben mit einem CNC-Model, was sie auf dieser Maschine bearbeiten wollen, dann drücken sie eine Taste auf der Maschine, sagt hier mein Model-Spektrum, dann baut diese Kiste eine VoIP-Verbindung zu deren Callcenter auf, dann hast du direkt an der Maschine eine Telefonverbindung zu jemanden in dem Callcenter, der sich per Screensharing deine Maschine übers VPN ranholt. Übrigens, hier Screensharing, dann kann ich sagen, hier die Kante musst du weiter abrunden, oder da kommst du nicht in diese Kante, weil da kommt dein Werkzeug nicht hin.
Das andere Ding im Weg ist?
Genau. Und er sagt, er sollte das für dich modifizieren, dann sagst du ja, mach mal. Oder du machst das, wie er gesagt hat. Und dann sagt er, schönen Tag noch, viel Spaß, wenn irgendwann das Druck wieder in den Knopf. So, das ist halt so die Realität da drauf.
Und wie viele Fälle davon haben die so pro Tag?
Die haben da richtig einen 30-Leute-Kurs hinter sitzen für diese Maschinen. Krass. Und es sind qualifizierte Leute, die da sitzen.
Okay, also, aber das heißt, ich als Firma, als Kunde von denen, wie wahrscheinlich ist das, dass ich den Dienst in Anspruch nehmen muss? Könnte ich sagen, okay, ich schließe die Maschine erst ans Internet an, wenn ich den Support brauche?
Könntest du wahrscheinlich tun, aber so komplex wie das Zeug ist, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du mehrmals am Tag brauchst in einem Park von mehreren Maschinen groß. Also spezifisch halt für so Sachen wie, wenn du halt relativ flexible produktionen hast, wo du häufiger mit wechselnden Modellen zu tun hast, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr groß. Und das ist auch übrigens so ein Ding, so Industrie 4.0. Das heißt ja immer flexible produktion und so. Das ist halt eines von diesen vielen Elementen an Industrie 4.0, die halt irgendwie sagen, so wie soll denn das funktionieren?
Na, mit der Cloud.
Mit der Cloud und künstliche Intelligenz. Künstliche Intelligenz in der Cloud.
Ich hab da diese Werbung gesehen. Leverage Infinite Cloud Resources. Irgendwo so ein Schlangeöl-Bullshit. Aber da dachte ich so, das bringt es gut auf den Punkt. Das ist so das Modell, was die Leute von der Cloud haben. Infinite. Ja gut, aber das war jetzt das Treiber- und Hardware-Problem. Es gibt ja noch andere Facetten.
Genau, dann gibt es halt noch dieses Update-Problem.
Und das ist zum Kotzen, wer schon mal Windows geupdatet hat. Irgendwie so ein frisches Windows 7 installieren ist ja die Kratzer auf Erden. Bist du irgendwie Tage damit beschäftigt, irgendwelche Patches einzuspielen? Office genauso. Ja, also ich...
Hat Microsoft keine Commutative Patches?
Ich... Ja und nein. Also bei Windows 10 haben sie das jetzt endlich eingeführt.
Denn doch.
Aber es ist trotzdem so, dass dieses Windows-Update erstmal irgendwie so eine Art Manifest runterlädt mit allen verfügbaren Patches und dann die rausfiltert, die dich nicht betreffen. Und das allein dauert schon fucking ewig, weil das eben dynamisches Dokument ist, was nicht auf dem CDN liegt, sondern das muss von Microsoft kommen. Und in diesem Manifest... Ja, pass auf, der Trick ist nämlich der. In dem Manifest steht drin, welche Patches es gibt und ein Hash. Und dann lädt er den eigentlichen Patch von einem CDN, dem Microsoft auch nicht trauen möchte. Ja, weil das nämlich irgendein Drittanbieter ist. So und das heißt, die Sicherheit von dem Update-Mechanismus passiert daraus, dass das Manifest aus einer sicheren Quelle nämlich von Microsoft geladen wird. Und dass du dann, wenn du ein Hash, dass du anhand des Hashes sehen kannst, ob das Update, was du gerade gezogen hast, korrekt ist oder nicht, ohne HTTPS machen zu müssen und ohne dass Microsoft dem CDN trauen muss. Ja, darauf basiert die Sicherheit. Und es ist an sich nicht doof, aber das heißt eben, dass du ordentlich, ordentlich, eigentlich auch nicht notwendigerweise. Die könnten auch einfach ein bisschen mehr in ihre Infrastruktur investieren. Aber aus deren Sicht reicht es halt, wenn irgendwie einen Tag nach dem Patch Day oder zwei Tage nach dem Patch Day immer noch bei einzelnen Leuten irgendwelche Patches eintrudeln. Und ich habe das auch im Blog gerade ausgeführt. Die Zeit, also es gibt inzwischen Tools, was heißt inzwischen, schon seit Jahren, gibt es Tools, da tust du die version vor dem Patch rein und die version nach dem Patch. Und dann sagt er dir, guck mal, hier hat er geändert. Und dann dauert es, ich sag mal, ein Tag, Maximum, bis du einen Exploit klar hast, aus dem Patch einfach rausgefunden hast, was sie gefixt haben und einen Exploiter hast, der das benutzt. Also das reicht vielleicht nicht immer für Code execution, aber manchmal eben doch. Und das heißt, ein Tag ist im Grunde die absolute Obergrenze dafür, dass ein Patch, der verfügbar ist, überall ausgerollt sein muss. Ansonsten bist du tot. Und da sind wir nicht mal entfernt dann, aus meiner Sicht. Sondern es passiert immer wieder. Gerade wenn du ein wirklich frisches Windows 7 installierst von DVD, da haben sie in der Zwischenzeit irgendwie nochmal was mit dem Update-Mechanismus gefixt. Und du musst erstmal einen Zwischen-Patch manuell einspielen, sonst bleibt das Update hängen. So Geschichten, wo du denkst, das darf doch nicht wahr sein. Also Microsoft ist alles andere als ohne Schaden an der Stelle. Die haben sich da einfach einen Gutteil des Problems selbst hinzugefügt. Aber man muss eben auch fairerweise sagen, ich weiß nicht, wieviel Windows es gibt, aber ich sag mal eine Milliarde, oder? Vielleicht zwei Milliarden. Also es gibt verdammt viele Windows da draußen. Und die die Infrastruktur vorzuhalten, die alle innerhalb von einem Tag zu patchen, das ist halt auch nicht trivial. Ja, muss man einfach sagen.
Na gut, aber am Ende ist doch die Frage...
Also eine Sache, wo ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ist, ob die ein Delta ausrollen, oder ob die einfach die DLL neu ausrollen. Ich glaube nämlich, du kriegst einfach das komplette File. Und das heißt auch, es ist viel mehr Daten, die übertragen werden müssen.
Ja, na gut, ich meine ja...
Weiß nicht, ob sie das gefixt haben, aber als ich da vor ein paar Jahren mal drauf geguckt hab, war es so, dass der Patch ist... Gerade bei Office sieht man das immer gut, da kriegst du dann irgendwie den installierten Office. Und er sagt dir, Office installiert man ja aus dem Netz. Und dann sagt er dir, du musst jetzt 800 MB runterladen, dann lädst du 800 MB Rufluchen drunter. Dann sagt er dir, Patches gefunden, du musst jetzt 1,4 Gigabyte Patches laden. Denkst du so, rein rechnerisch kann das doch hier nicht hinkommen gerade. Und wenn er mit denen durch ist, sagt er dir, und jetzt gibt es die zweite Runde an Patches. Und top, die sind ja nicht so viel, aber du bist da mehrere iterationen jeweils beschäftigt. Und diese, also ich...
Hat Apple irgendwie besser im Griff?
Ich weiß nicht. Ja, na ja. Hm, also da will ich mir jetzt auch nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster lehnen.
Zumindest haben sie irgendwie...
Apple hat irgendwie mehr als eine Größenordnung weniger Benutzer. Also insofern...
Nee, aber sie haben kumulative Patches. Und die wirklich auch gut funktionieren.
Gut, also die hat Windows inzwischen auch. Aber das hat halt auch Nachteile, so ein kumulativer Patch. Der heißt eben, wenn du ein akutes Problem gefixt haben willst, musst du den kumulativen Patch ziehen, der auch die ganzen anderen Probleme daneben mitfixed, die du schon längst gefixt hast. Was du eigentlich haben willst, ist sowas wie Chrome.
Die machen kumulative Matrix-Patches, das heißt, die rechnen halt aus, von welcher version kommst du, und dann haben sie die Download-Files generiert. Also nicht durchgehend, aber im Wesentlichen haben sie halt für die Minor-Releases dann die Diffs generiert. Also du kannst halt von einer Minor-Release Punkt 1 auf einer Minor-Release Punkt 4 gehen, ohne dass du dazwischen noch irgendwas brauchst. Aber Chrome hat es tatsächlich am besten gemacht.
Also Chrome macht es halt so, dass der sich anguckt, welche version du hast und zu welcher version du willst. Und dann gibt er dir einen Bytecode, der, wenn man ihn ausführt, diesen Patch durchführt. Und der ist halt stark komprimiert. Und das ist eigentlich richtig so, wie man es haben will. Aber das ist ein schwieriges Problem, auch das richtig zu machen. Und also ich würde da an Microsoft-Stelle noch ein bisschen nachlegen. Aber das sagt sich natürlich immer leichter. Ja, das ist ein schwieriges Problem.
Also was mich halt irgendwie so ein bisschen verstört ist, du hattest ja irgendwann mal erzählt, was die für einen Aufwand treiben, halt um so App-Compatibility-Testing zu machen für neue versionen.
Jaja, das ist unglaublich. Man hat von außen keine Vorstellungen. Also ich hab damals eine Story gehört, da ging es um Eudora, falls ich noch jemand erinnere. Das ist so ein 16-Bit-Mail-Gammel-Programm. Und da gab es irgendwie, wie war denn das? Also die Story ging so, ich hab das nicht verifiziert, das ist mir so erzählt worden, dass Eudora einen undokumentierten, eine interne Windows-Datenstruktur benutzt hat, die in ihrem Prozess irgendwie gemapt ist und irgendwie an Offset 15 den Wert so und so erwartet hat. Und dadurch, dass diese Struktur aber nie dokumentiert war, hat Microsoft sozusagen, das hat sich geändert mit einer neuen windows-version. So und dann funktionierte Eudora nicht mehr. Und dann hat Microsoft gesagt, okay, also wenn der Exe-Name gleich Eudora.exe, dann wird dieses Zwischenlayer dazwischen geschoben, das nennt sich eine Schimm, ein Layer, das gibt es viele für verschiedene Anwendungen. Und der fummelt dann die Daten wieder so zurecht, dass Eudora noch läuft. Also auf dem Niveau arbeiten die da für AppCompat. Und wenn man sich das überlegt, kann man überhaupt nicht verstehen, dass es irgendwelche chinesischen Treiber gibt, die nicht doch irgendwie zu laufen zu kriegen sind. Also Schimm sind für User-Space und Treiber ist wieder was anderes. Ich vereinfache das hier ein bisschen. Aber also eine der Gründe, warum alte Treiber möglicherweise heute nicht mehr laufen, ist, dass man eben inzwischen erweiterte Apis hat, die supportet werden müssen. Also ein Grafiktreiber muss zum Beispiel neuere DirectX Sachen supporten. Sonst wollen die Leute die nicht haben. Oder Druckertreiber sind heutzutage User-Space-Treiber und nicht mehr im Kernel-Mode, weil die einfach alle so grottenscheiße waren. Also es gibt da schon zwei, drei Sachen, die man anfassen muss, aber das Treiber-Modell an sich ist steinalt. Bei Windows und geht zurück bis NT. Und eigentlich laufen alte NT-Treiber also konzeptionell auf jeden Fall auch unter neueren windows-versionen und sollten auch einfach direkt funktionieren. Also die meisten. Nicht alle, gibt Ausnahmen. Aber gerade bei so GPIO-Geschichten gibt es meines Erachtens keine Ausrede. Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich nur die Signatur, die da im Weg steht. Und die kostet so was wie 100 Dollar. Und da hast du dann ein Abo für ein Jahr, bis Developer, kannst du alle signieren. Also ich bin entsetzt, dass es Firmen gibt, die Produkte für Windows verkaufen und dann keine Signatur für ihren Treiber haben. Kann ich überhaupt nicht verstehen. Also bei Open Source, okay. Dass irgendein Open Source-Frickler keinen Bock hat, irgendwie 100 Dollar auszugeben für das Privileg, Microsoft ein Verkaufsargument für ihre Produkte zu geben, okay. Aber jemand, der irgendwie Geräte verkauft, die fünfstellig kosten, dass der irgendwie keine 100 Dollar ausgibt, tut mir leid, verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich nicht wirklich zu verstehen. Andererseits, wenn man sich so anguckt, so anderes Thema, wenn man halt irgendwie so was wie irgendwelche Bahndisplays oder so was, um nur mal ein random Beispiel herauszupicken.
Rein zufällig jetzt mal so in den Topf drücken.
Also zufällig so. Dann ist es ja häufiger dann auch so, dass die werden dann halt von irgendwelchen kleinen Buden gebaut, die halt froh sind, wenn ihre technische Lösung funktioniert. Und die dann halt, wenn sie halt irgendwie da die anfassen und da irgendwie Dinge dran tun, immer wieder in Probleme laufen. So, die halt irgendwie also außer Security keinen objektiven Grund haben zu updaten.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, dass es nicht so ist, sondern dass es so ist, dass der kleine Hersteller zur Bahn geht und sagt, hier ist unsere Digital Signage solution und hier ist unser Support-Angebot. Und die Bahn guckt auf den Preis und den Support und sagt, auch weißt du was, ist doch nur ein Anzeigebild. Ja, so meile ich mir das zurecht. Den Support brauchen wir nicht. So, das ist meine Theorie.
Na gut, ich meine, wenn du halt irgendwie richtig rechnest, dann müsstest du halt irgendwie so, dass sie 20 Prozent Support pro Jahr auf so einen Produktpreis rechnen.
Oder du machst das fucking selber. Das ist ein Windows PC. Das kann mir doch keiner erklären, dass das so schwer ist, da den PC zu updaten. Die haben Netzzugang, ja? Offensichtlich, sie haben SMB-Zugang, sonst wären sie nicht infiziert worden.
Nee, aber sie müssen ja ihre Software. Ich meine, ganz viel von diesem Zeug ist ja offensichtlich Software, die halt so rotten ist und so schlecht geschrieben und irgendwie auf so viele interne Apples abzielt und so.
Glaub ich nicht. Glaub ich alles überhaupt nicht. Ich glaube, dass sie einfach gesagt haben, hör mal, Updates kostet irgendwie Netzwerk. Netzwerk wollen wir lieber irgendwie, haben wir nicht so viel, kostet Geld, schalt mal ab. Ist meine Theorie. Du, es gibt viele beschissene Software, aber Software, die so beschissen ist, dass du Windows-Updates ausschaltest, weil sie nicht geht, bei einer Signage-Geschichte?
Nein.
Also wir wissen es nicht aus erster Hand.
Genau, also wir hätten gerne, also genau, vielleicht will uns das ja mal ein Bahninsider liegen. Genau, beziehungsweise wie interessiert uns das tatsächlich, was ist denn der Grund? Also insofern schreibt uns mal ein Mail, wenn ihr irgendwie aus eurer eigenen Erfahrung oder wenn ihr gehört habt, bei jemand anderem, der da solche Erfahrungen hat.
Genau, wir fragen für einen Freund.
Genau, wir fragen für einen Freund. Wieso passiert denn das? Also warum sind solche Systeme, also ich mein, wie zum Beispiel bei so einer Signature zu dusen, verstehe ich auch nicht, warum die überhaupt auf dem Windows ist. Ja, also selbst mit einem, irgendwie mit einem alten 2.6. Körner Linux wärst du ja noch besser bedient damit, ja, also das ist ja...
Hätte halt bei Mirai teilgenommen.
Hätte aber bei Mira teilgenommen, ja, okay. Gut, also vielleicht aber jedenfalls die Frage, die sich aber schon stellt, ist eben, also akut stellt anhand dieser Geschichte, ist halt, eigentlich brauchen wir wirklich für jedes einzelne Gerät, das Netzwerk hat, irgendwie eine sinnvolle Update-Strategie. Anders wird es halt nicht mehr funktionieren.
Also was ich ja faszinierend finde, ist, dass so eine Windows-Lizenz tatsächlich Geld kostet, ja, nicht sehr, nicht kostenlos. Wenn du dir da also, also wenn du mal durchzählst, wie viel Anzeigetafeln an so einem Bahnhof rumhängen und wie viel Bahnhöfe das gibt.
Ist da in jedem Windows drin oder ist das jetzt nicht mehr in der Steuerung?
Das ist natürlich die Frage an der Stelle.
Ich denke nicht.
Aber ich stelle mir vor, dass das jeweils irgendwie, also wenn, wenn... So, aus meiner Erfahrung ist das irgendwie ein VGA-Kabel. Und so viele Videoausgänge gibt es nicht pro PC. Also, wir haben ja mal, wir haben mal im Club so ein Panel gehabt. Das war relativ anders. Das war allerdings auch vom Flughafen nicht wunderbar.
Das war aber seriell angesteuert worden.
Genau, das ist seriell angesteuert worden. So hätte man das früher gemacht. Aber heute hat man hier diese hochauflösenden TFT-Displays. Und da gibt es dann wahrscheinlich jeweils ein DVI-Kabel.
Na ja, vielleicht. Aber gut, ich meine, so ein XPM-Badlet kostet auch wirklich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, kostet ein 20 oder so. Also das ist wirklich nicht teuer.
Nee, aber multiplizierbar mit der Anzahl, ja.
Na ja, wenn du dafür irgendwie 10.000 Euro für so ein Display dahinhängst, dann stört nicht die 20.
Wie viel würdest du für so ein Display ausgeben?
Na ja, also wenn ich jetzt mal so...
Du meinst jetzt das Große, was irgendwie die halbe Saalwand, irgendwie?
Ja, so. Würde ich schon davon ausgehen, dass sie... Obwohl, ich meine selbst diese...
Also was bei der Bahn ja auch betroffen war, sind ja diese Zeichen am Bahnsteig gewesen, die der nächste Zug ist.
Und ich glaube, das ist halt schon eher so, keine Ahnung, Feldbus-Ansteuerung. Ach gut. Ich finde, das ist was, was uns unsere Hörer mal irgendwie schreiben können.
Interessante Frage jedenfalls.
Also ich finde diese Frage halt wirklich sehr interessant, weil irgendwie so hier, also was ich so gesehen habe, so auch gerade so Industrie-Steuerung und irgendwie Laborgerätesteuerung und Messgerätesteuerung und so, ist halt häufiger mal eben so, das macht den Eindruck, als wenn die Leute, die so was entwickeln, gar nicht erst auf die Idee kommen, da halt irgendwie was anderes zu nehmen, als Windows, unter anderem deswegen, weil sie für Windows halt am einfachsten Entwickler finden. Und wenn du halt so ein User-Interface entwickeln musst und halt irgendwie noch ein User-Interface für Support und Maintenance dafür und für Eingabe von Daten und so haben willst und für Export und so, dann nimmst du halt so ein Windows, weil alle Leute Windows nehmen.
Wir sollten vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen drauf eingehen, warum Updates nicht eingespielt werden, wenn sie da sind. Das ist ja nicht nur, dass es keine Updates gibt, weil du ein altes Windows hast, sondern es gibt auch viele Fälle. Also in diesem Fall war der Patch für die neueren windows-versionen zwei Monate verfügbar knapp. Da gibt es also eigentlich aus meiner Sicht nicht viel Ausreden, zumindest für Privatbenutzer. Warum ist denn das den großen Firmen so, dass die Patches nicht direkt ausrollen?
Na die meisten großen Firmen haben so einen Prozess, dass sie Updates erstmal testen. Das heißt, wenn Microsoft sagt, hier ein neues Update zum Patch Day, dann tun die das in ihren Testing-Pool. In diesem Testing-Pool läuft alles Software, die sie in dem Unternehmen für relevant und kritisch halten. Also meistens irgendwelche SAP-Anwendungen und irgendwie was sie sonst noch so haben, an Zeug, was sie speziell haben, hacken lassen. Und dann testen die dagegen. Und diese Software ist häufiger gerne auch mal ein bisschen komplizierter. Das heißt also, die müssen dann halt so mal alles an funktionalität testen, wo sie glauben, dass es betroffen sein könnte. Zumal halt ja bei der Microsoft-Patch ist jetzt auch nicht immer so 100 Prozent klar, was sie noch alles gepatcht haben, außer den Sachen, die sie angesagt haben. Was halt dazu führt, dass man dann lieber auch mal testet, ob es dann noch druckt und ob dann halt irgendwie der Bildschirm schon noch funktioniert, ob die in der Firma verwendete zum Beispiel authentication-lösung mit irgendwie NFC-Karte gegen NFC funktioniert. Single Sign-On funktioniert, ob irgendwie die Netzwerkverbindung zum Fileserver irgendwie so ist, wie man es haben will, ob der Special VPN-Client, den man auf der Kiste benutzt, noch irgendwie super funktioniert und so. Das ist natürlich ein relativ großer Aufwand. Also so Testing ist ja ohnehin schon ein großer Aufwand.
Moment, man spricht hier schon über den mir wichtigen Punkt, bist du einfach hinweggegangen. Microsoft haftet nicht, wenn ihre Updates nicht gehen.
Korrekt.
Ja, das ist die Wurzel des Problems. Wenn ich also eine große Firma habe und ich setze Windows ein und es gibt einen Patch und der explodiert und meine ganze Firma ist offline, dann ist das mein Problem, nicht Microsofts Problem. Und das ist branchenweit so. Und daher haben viele große Firmen im Übrigen auch völlig zu Recht mehrfach die Erfahrung gemacht. Ich installiere den Patch und mir platzten die Sachen. Office kommt nicht mehr hoch, gab es alles schon.
Oder SAP funktioniert nicht mehr oder sowas?
Ja. Dazu kommt, dass es teilweise auch zertifikationsprobleme gibt, große Firmen. Also bei der Bahn zum Beispiel, die können nicht einfach Software irgendwo updaten, sondern da gibt es einen Prozess für. Und wenn es an einer kritischen Stelle ist, wie sage ich mal, Stellwerk oder so, dann will das Eisenbahnbundesamt da nochmal drüber gucken und so. Also es gibt durchaus valide Argumente oder zumindest ein regulatorisches Umfeld, in dem man nicht einfach einen Patch einspielen kann. Auf der anderen Seite ist es eben so, dass man dann verwundbar ist. Und die Antwort der Firmen ist im Allgemeinen, pass auf, da machen wir noch eine extra Firewall drum rum und dann kaufen wir hier noch ein bisschen Schlangenöl und dann kaufen wir da noch ein bisschen Schlangenöl. Dann machen wir hier noch ein intrusion detection System und ein intrusion prevention System und dann machen wir hier noch ein FireEye für die Malware-Erkennung und hoffen einfach, wenn wir hier einen Lückel haben, weil wir einen Patch nicht eingespielt haben, dass der Antivirus die Malware findet, bevor sie das ausnutzt.
Oder halt signature-based IDS.
Ja, oder was auch immer. Was der Schlangen öffnet, ja. Das ist ja das Schöne bei Schlangenöl, wenn das alte Schlangenöl nicht mehr funktioniert, machst du noch eine Packung neues Schlangenöl drüber, dann ist alles wieder gut.
Und wenn man sich so anguckt, wie die so vorgehen, ist es häufig auch so, dass sie Patches selber kommunulieren. Das heißt also, die sagen, okay, der Testingaufwand, um halt irgendwie die Gesamtes auf Versuche, diese in den Großunternehmen fahren zu testen, ist halt so groß, dass sie halt nicht mit dem monatlichen Patch day mitgehen, sondern sozusagen daraus quartalsweise Patches akkumulieren, weil sie sagen...
Das ist eine der schlechtesten Ideen, die man im IT-Umfeld überhaupt haben kann. Denn je mehr Kram auf Halde liegt und gepatcht werden muss, desto größer ist das Risiko, dass es am Ende nicht klappt. Das heißt, der einzige gangbare Weg ist immer so schnell wie möglich patchen. Schön, also gerne ein bisschen testen. Aber wie ich vorhin schon gesagt habe, wenn es länger als einen Tag zwischen der Patch kommt raus und der Patch wird installiert ist...
Das ist das Problem....
bin ich angreifbar. Und das wird einfach unterschätzt. Die Leute sagen dann, ja gut, wer greift uns schon an? Das hört man sogar aus Firmen, die tatsächlich, also legitime Ziele von ausländischen Geheimdiensten sind. So, ach, uns greift schon keiner an, wir sind doch nur ein kleiner Player. Ja, die Leute, weißte man, man rationalisiert sich das halt zurecht. So ja, ach komm, irgendwie das wird schon nicht passieren. Und wenn doch, war es halt Pech. Ja, dann kommt man so diese, diese, diese ach, naja, das ist dann halt irgendwie Schicksal. Ja, es war halt durch. Es gab neulich diesen tollen Fall. Ich glaube, das hatten wir sogar nach Nord schon. Ich als der eine chinesische CEO meinte so, ja, also das werden ja fast alle Firmen irgendwann von Hackern. Und jetzt sind wir halt mal dran.
Genau. Jetzt hat halt gehagelt.
Genau. Also das ist diese Perspektive, die sich dann auch ändert. Wenn ich einmal anfange, mir so, das nennt man technical debt, nennt man das in der Industrie. Also wenn ich so einen Schuldenberg aufbaue aus Sachen, die eigentlich noch gepatcht werden müssten oder so alte, alte Software-Gabbel-Scheiße, die eigentlich mal ordentlich gemacht werden müsste. Und dann ja, das schieb ich von mir her. Oder wie hier, wenn ich hier ein Windows habe, um meinen Laser anzuschließen und es müsste eigentlich mal jemand, aber ach na ja, weißt du so, das ist halt Schulden. Und die schleppt man mit sich rum. Und wie das mit Schulden so ist, da gibt's dann Zinsen drauf. Das wird nicht besser, wenn man es liegen lässt. Ja.
Na gut, wie kommen wir denn jetzt da raus? Was sind denn die Auswege?
Da ist das nicht so einfach.
Also wir hatten ja schon einen Punkt angesprochen, nämlich Haftung. Also es wird wahrscheinlich kein Victimum führen, dass wir die eine oder andere Form von Haftung irgendwie bekommen. Das heißt also, dass Unternehmen, Softwareanbieter und so weiter, für das, was sie da tun, halt haften, was halt wiederum dazu führen wird, dass es so was wie eine Haftpflichtversicherung geben werden muss, weil die Schäden halt dann noch gerne mal ein bisschen größer werden können, wenn man Pech hat. Und da gibt es natürlich alle Feinheiten und Details, die man da beachten muss. Also insofern, dass zum Beispiel Startups nicht aus dem Markt irgendwie geschmissen werden. Die Frage halt, wie monetarisiert man so einen Schaden? Also wie sagt man, wie viel Schaden ist eigentlich entstanden? Welche Möglichkeiten hat man überhaupt nachzuweisen, an wem es jetzt eigentlich liegt? Also ganz viel wird jetzt momentan über so Betriebsausfallversicherungen abgewickelt. Und da hat mir einer aus der Versicherungsbranche erzählt, die Betriebsausfallversicherung zieht häufiger auch mal, weil die Unternehmen gepatcht haben. Weil sie halt irgendwas gepatcht haben, wo sie dachten, das geht schon. Aber die funktion ist ausgefallen. Und das wird dann halt gedeckt von der Betriebsausfallversicherung, weil es halt höhere Gewalt ist, wenn der Patch halt nicht funktioniert hat.
Also ich finde das so zum Kotzen, das ist alles Schicksal, was wir hinnehmen müssen, finde ich furchtbar.
Naja, aus der Sicht eines Nutzers ist es halt höhere Gewalt.
Ich denke immer an die nächste generation, die einfach aufwächst in dieser Scheiße und es nicht anders kennt. Und ich denke, ja, so ist das als Software, geht halt kaputt.
Naja, vor allen Dingen, wenn du halt irgendwie dann denkst, dass sie jetzt damit IoT und Internet of Things bauen, mit genau derselben Kutze.
Ich denke an die Cloud. Ich denke mir so, ja, weißte, wenn meine Geräte alle nicht funktionieren, der Cloud-Manager ist jemand und dann ist er dafür zuständig, dass es funktioniert und es ist doch ein Deal, mach ich doch. Und es ist auch noch kostenlos.
verantwortungsdiffusion.
Also ich finde das entsetzlich, dass wir uns gerade daran gewöhnen, dass es halt alles Scheiße ist und keiner findet, dass man da was tun muss. Ich bin da der Don Quixote, der immer noch gegen die Windmühlen hier... Irgendeiner muss da was tun und wer, wenn nicht wir, wann wenn nicht jetzt.
Also am Ende läuft es halt darauf hinaus, dass wir halt bessere Software brauchen. Das wird sich halt nicht vermeiden lassen.
Wir brauchen bessere Software. Und übrigens, ich glaube, also erstens habe ich ja mit einigen Juristen mich unterhalten und die haben mir alle unisono versichert, dass es keine Produkthaftung für Software geben wird, weil geht nicht. Aber andere Modelle wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht. Ich glaube, man kann natürlich immer sagen, okay, wir müssen vote with your wallet, wie der Amerikaner sagt. Man kauft einfach keine scheiß Produkte mehr. Aber das ist unrealistisch.
Naja, wieso?
Es passiert nicht.
Also, naja, guckst dir an, die Leute kaufen Apple. Naja, Moment. Also, minimale Anforderungen ist ja, dass eine Firma ansagt, für wie lange sie Hardware supportet. Also, das wäre jetzt so das unterste Level, von was ich von meinem Start möchte, ist, dass deine Firma hat zudem gesagt, wenn du ein Device verkaufst, was Netzwerk hat, also wo es irgendeine Art von Anglosvektor von draußen drauf gibt, so sei es auch nur irgendein beschissenes IoT-Protokoll, muss auf dem Ding ein Label kleben, bis zu welchem Datum du Software-Updates auf den aktuellen Stand der Technik für dieses Gerät empfangen wirst.
Ich habe in meinem IoT-Talk vorgeschlagen, dass die Europäische Behörde für Elektroschrottvermeidung pro Produktkategorie sagen soll, wie lange das Mindestsupport-Datum für diese Art von Gerät ist. Und mit Support ist nicht gemeint, wird kostenlos repariert, sondern man kriegt Updates.
Security Updates, also ist halt die Minimalanforderung.
Und es gibt eine Reparaturmöglichkeit, nicht nur irgendwie wegschmeißen, neu machen.
Ja, also aber diese Anforderung zu sagen, wie lange gibt's Security Updates auf den aktuellen Stand der Technik? Das ist sozusagen die absolute unterste Grenze und die wird sich halt nur über statische Regulierungen erzwingen lassen. Weil dann geht es halt eben nicht mehr, dass du halt irgendwie bei Aldi ein Android-Tablet verkaufst, was halt irgendwie schon, wenn es gekauft wird, wenn es verkauft wird, schon verhaltet und unsicher ist. Schon der Baseband-Hersteller von diesem Ding sagt, dafür wird es nie wieder ein Patch geben, weil es abgekündigt ist Produkt. Oder da halt ein gammliges Ultra-Uralt-Android drauf ist, wo du auch weißt, da wird es nie wieder ein Update geben. Und da muss ich tatsächlich Apple mal in Schutz nehmen. Also mein Lieblingsbeispiel für den Vorträgen ist, ich frag die Leute mal, wer von ihnen hat da noch ein iPad 1? Und da melden sich immer eine Handvoll Leute im Saal. Und ein iPad 1 kannst du eigentlich nicht mehr gut in gewissen Szenen bringen, weil das letzte Security-Update für, glaube ich, drei Jahre her oder so. Das heißt also, aber es funktioniert noch. Es ist ein Gerät, was immer noch funktioniert.
Und die Aldi-Androids funktionieren auch noch. Ist halt unsicher, darf man nicht ins Netz hängen.
Ja, also wenn ich so in meine Schütte gucke mit den alten Produkten, da sind relativ wenige Apple-Produkte drin. Die meisten funktionieren nämlich einfach.
Ja, das liegt aber an dir, nicht an den Apple-Produkten.
Nicht an der Hardware.
Ja, ja.
Gut. Anyway, die Folgerung muss halt eigentlich sein zu sagen, ok, du musst einfach als Hersteller einen Lebenszyklus, Softwareupdates, mindestens Security-Updates, Feature-Updates, kann man auch darüber reden, mindestens Security-Updates einplanen, gewährleisten und einpreisen. Und dann kannst du halt auf der Basis halt anfangen, tatsächlich zu compiten, genau wie wir es jetzt bei Waschmaschinen, ja?
Du, das ist aber nicht so einfach zu ziehen, die Linie. Also ich will als Beispiel mal nehmen, bei Windows ist es so, dass die ssl-implementation auf XP die ganzen modernen SciFi einfach nicht kann. Ja, elliptische Kurven mit Diffie-Helmen kann der halt nicht. So und damit...
Brauche ich auch nicht.
Ja, wenn du Chrome oder Firefox hast, brauchst du es nicht. Aber das heißt, der IE auf dem alten XP fällt nach heutigen Standards durch und kann nicht... im Internet kommunizieren.
Wieso? Wenn er noch irgendwie mindestens 2048 mit RSA kann und AES kann, dann ist er...
Aber ohne Diffie-Helmen, also keine Forward-Secrecy.
Na gut, ok, da kann man sich drüber streiten.
Ja, aber das sagt Microsoft, ja, das ist aber kein Security-Update, sondern das ist halt ein Feature, was damals noch nicht gab. Darauf will ich ja hinaus.
Na gut, da muss man halt Standertechnik definieren. Also das ist das, was wegen ich halt immer sage, so der nächste Schritt danach.
Was ich sagen will, der Teufel ist ein Detail. Ich sag nicht, es geht nicht.
Nee, was ich sage ist halt nur, ist schwierig. Zertifizierung funktioniert nicht, wissen wir alle so, weil irgendwie mit Zertifizierung kommen wir irgendwie da nicht weiter, weil Zertifizierung dauert zu lang, ist viel zu teuer. Was wir brauchen, ist halt ein kollektiv definierter Standertechnik, also mein Vorschlag dazu ist zu sagen, der Staat geht hin und macht den Monorater und sagt, ok, wir bringen mal irgendwie Industrie und Akademie und die Hacker und irgendwie wir sonst noch ein anderes Art zusammen und wir definieren mal zusammen, was sind denn so die Minimale Anforderungen, die man haben muss. Und das erneuen, weil von mir aus alle drei Monate, so und wenn du mehr als ein Zyklus hinter dem Standertechnik zurück bist, dann hast du halt irgendwie ein Problem. Dann kannst du halt einfach nicht mehr sagen, dass du noch Standertechnik bist. So und dann muss man vielleicht noch festlegen, ok, wenn du halt Hersteller bist und du dir wird halt ein Buck gemeldet, der halt irgendwie exploitable ist und da gibt es immer mal eine CVE für, um mal irgendeinen Bar hoch zu hängen. Also ist halt so klar, dass die Vulnerability wirklich existiert und nachvollziehbar ist, dann hast du halt irgendwie maximal 60 Tage, um es zu patchen und es auszurollen. So wäre halt einfach mal zu sagen, so mal klare Ansagen, Stempel drauf und ich finde ja super, was Google da macht mit Project Zero, dass die halt einfach so gnadenlos sagen, ihr habt 90 Tage und ihr habt einfach mal 90 Tage. Das sind halt so muss man da halt vorgehen.
Nur schade, dass Google das machen muss und nicht das BSI. Das würde ich mir ja wünschen. Eigentlich ist Aufgabe des Staates einfach mal so richtig, die Wirtschaft einmal drauf zu pissen.
Na ja.
So hat es jemanden geschmeckt. Ich meine, Google.
Zur Ordnung zu rufen.
Das Schöne ist ja, dass Google das auch mit sich selbst macht. Das fand ich ja. Das haben sie demonstriert, dass sie also an der Stelle keine... Das war auch, glaube ich, für die... Das war auch genau der Hintergrund, glaube ich.
Ja, ich glaube, es war auch so.
Gut, aber jedenfalls, das Problem ist groß und schwierig und wenn ihr die Wahl habt, spielt die Patches ein.
Genau, spielt die Patches ein und zwar so schnell, wie es irgendwie geht. Also, auch noch so ein Punkt, der wichtig ist in der aktuellen Cyberdebatte, was ich unbedingt im Gesetz haben will, ist ein explizites Verbot für Geheimdienste und Polizeibehörden, Software-Update-Mechanismen zu einspielen von Exploits, also von treu anderen aus zu nutzen. Weil, wenn das passiert und das erste Mal hochbar wird, dann sind wir sowas von einem Eimer, weil die Leute aufhören werden, Updates einzuspielen und Patches einzuspielen. In dem Umblick ist wirklich einfach mal vorbeigekommen.
Gibt es jetzt schon Leute, die aus genau der Angst herausholen?
Ja, aber da braucht es halt wirklich ein absolutes, explizites No-Excuses-Verbot, weil wenn das passiert, dass Update-Mechanismen halt benutzt werden, um Experts zu, beziehungsweise Trojaner, zu verbreiten von staatlicher Seite, dann ist halt, können wir das eigentlich komplett lassen mit dieser IT-Security und einfach nur noch irgendwas mit Holzerloch-Ideen machen.
Eine Sache möchte ich noch ansprechen. Es ist nicht nur ein Sicherheitsloch, sondern es sind auch Design-Schwächen. Ja, also nicht nur so ein Bug, den man fixen kann, sondern es sind auch so... Es gab so eine Beobachtung, was für Befehle die Ransomware absetzt. Und eine von denen, was eigentlich alle Ransomwares machen, ist, dass sie die Shadow-Copies erlöschen in Windows. Das ist jetzt nicht direkt ein Backup, aber darüber kann man manchmal noch Sachen restaurieren. Und die werden alle gelöscht. Und es gibt einen Kommandozahlenbefehl unter Windows, mit dem man sagen kann, lösche die alle. Und da gibt es eine option slash quiet. Und dann werden die gelöscht und es gibt keine nutzerinteraktion. Und das verstehe ich nicht. Was soll denn das? Das ist eine immer destruktive operation. An anderen Stellen haben sie diese UAC-Pop-ups und haben da nach oben verhandelt. Das ist die option, wo das hätte sein müssen, dass dann ein systemmodaler Dialog kommt, den du nicht einfach wegklicken kannst, der voll im Weg ist und der auch fünf Sekunden Pause macht, bevor du o'clock kicken kannst. Und wo steht Achtung, was sie gerade machen, ist sehr destruktiv, wenn sie das nicht wirklich ausgelöst haben und wissen, was sie tun. Und wir geben ihnen jetzt fünf Sekunden, dass sie sich wirklich genau Gedanken machen können, ob sie das machen wollen oder nicht. So, und dann irgendwie am besten mit einem Knopf, der der Maus noch ein bisschen ausweicht. Da gibt es einfach keine Ausrede für, wieso sowas eine quiet-option haben soll. Das muss, das darf nicht einfach im Hintergrund gehen. Da tut mir leid, da habe ich kein Verständnis für. Also, und es gibt aber viele so eine Detailsache. Hersteller sind seit Jahren damit weggekommen, diese Art von Fallstrick nicht einzubauen. Einfach systematisch die nicht einzubauen. Eine der Hauptgründe, warum Malware bei Windows über Mail so gut funktioniert, ist, weil Windows gesagt hat, hör mal, wir zeigen dateiextensionen nicht an. Und dann kommt die Malware und heißt.pdf.exe und die Leute denken, auch PDF kenn ich. Völlig überflüssig dieses Loch, wo einfach nur zu Schaden kommen. Der Anwender hat einfach keinen Vorteil davon, diese Art von Scheiße im Jahre 2017 immer noch Standard. Und da tut mir leid. Ja, also ich verstehe auch nicht, warum wir hier irgendwelche ISO und und was weiß ich, PCI-Standardisierung verhandeln und und diese diese Art von Mist wird geduldet. Ja, liebes BSI, tut mir eingefallen. Tretet da mal ein bisschen nach. Ja, das muss wehtun. Solche Produkte auszuliefern muss wehtun.
Gut, in diesem Sinne.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Genau, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wir haben da immer noch diesen Schletter-Button. Mal sehen, wie lange noch Patreon benutzen wir auch.
Ja, also Flatter ist ja übergegangen zu, wie heißen die? Ist gekauft worden von den AdBlock Plus-Worden.
Also müssen wir nochmal drüber nachdenken. Also wenn ihr noch nicht so zufrieden mit, nehmt den Patreon-Button. Ansonsten nehmen wir auch gerne noch Hinweise für andere interessante Services zur Förderung von Kunst und Kultur entgegen. Ansonsten wünschen wir euch viel Spaß, beim Zuhören gehabt zu haben.
Immer schön updaten.
Genau, immer schön updaten. Bis zum nächsten Mal.